[musique]
Lydia et Claude Bourguignon. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Lydia, est-ce que tu
peux commencer à te prop à te présenter
succintement ? Bah
Lydia Bourguignon. Euh avec Claude, on a
monté un laboratoire en 1989 au service
des agriculteurs pour leur permettre de
respecter leur sol et de faire une
alimentation
disons, je vais dire plus chargé, plus
énergétique et
moins moins chimiqué.
Claude
avec Lydia, voilà, on a tout fait
ensemble même nos enfants hein et donc
la maison, le laboratoire tout et c'est
vrai que ce laboratoire c'est très rare
laboratoire indépendant aux services des
agriculteurs pour leur apprendre à
protéger leur patrimoine parce qu'en
fait il décapitalise en ce moment les
agriculteurs. C'est le pire capitalisme
qu'on peut imaginer, c'est de perdre la
valeur. Il y a plus de sol fertiles, il
y a que des sols fertilisés. Ça ça c'est
une grosse différence.
C'est pas trop dur de bosser avec sa
femme ?
[rires]
Non, je enfin moi je crois pas. Je
laisse le répondre. [rires]
Non, parce qu'on on travaille dans à
travers toute la planète donc on a une
vie absolument passionnante. On
rencontre des acteurs de toute nation,
de tout continent et chaque fois qu'on
les aide et que et qu'on les a aidé à
s'échapper à l'agroindustrie, bah il
nous remercie. Donc du coup, on est
remercié tous les deux.
Aujourd'hui, on a décidé de vous faire
revenir parce qu'on vous a déjà reçu une
fois il y a à peu près 2 ans en
anticipation de tout un tas de choses.
On vous a fait revenir aujourd'hui parce
que comme vous avez pu le remarquer, il
y a la guerre avec l'Iran, il y a le D3
d'Ormous qui est en train de mettre tout
un tas de chaînes logistiques
perturbées. On a les engrais perturbés,
les pesticides perturbés, les rendements
perturbés,
le réalisateur qui fait des grands
gestes qui me perturbe.
On se retrouve on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec une crainte
de pénurie alimentaire ou d'inflation
dans les frigos. Claude, comment tu vois
les choses ? Comment tu anticipes les
choses ? Quels sont les éléments
précurseurs que tu peux noter qui ne
sont pas pris en considération par les
politiciens ? Tu nous raconteras avec ta
femme Lydia l'expérience que vous avez
pu avoir avec quelques députés qui vous
ont consulté pour savoir votre
perception de la chose. Vas-y Claude
carte blanche. Bah
disons, je crois que la grande erreur du
du 20e siècle, c'est d'avoir assimilé la
vie avec la matière. C'est l'erreur de
Descartes. C'est-à-dire qu'on a on s'est
dit d'ailleurs quand on parle de viande
dans le milieu, on parle de minerais. On
dit même plus la viande, le minerai.
C'est c'est devenu, il pensent que
on peut gérer la vie comme on gère la
taille d'un la taille d'une roue de
camion et cetera alors que c'est
complètement différent. La vie est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça. Et on a
fait du métier d'agriteur un métier, on
a dit c'est des ploues, c'est des alors
que c'est le métier le plus complexe du
monde. Faut connaître la le sol, faut
connaître la vie du sol, faut connaître
les rotations, les associations. Et ce
métier, on l'a complètement laissé
tomber. Il y a plus de formation
scientifique dans l'agronomie et qu'une
formation technique. Et là, on arrive
dans le mur. Et le problème, c'est
comment on va faire maintenant pour
redonner la fertilité à nos sols pour
refaire une vraie agriculture,
c'està-dire une ce que nous on appelle
avec Lydia l'agrologie, c'est-à-dire la
connaissance du champ pour comprendre un
petit peu comment on va gérer tout ça.
Et là, on n'est pas bien.
Qu'est-ce que tuentends ? On arrive dans
le mur. C'est
on arrive dans le mur. C'estàd que
maintenant c'est fini la la chute
d'activité biologique des sols, la chute
de leur fertilité ne va pas se restaurer
en claquant des doigts. C'est-à-dire
c'est pas comme je change de machine
dans une industrie puis où je mets un
robot et puis non, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça. C'est quand un sol a
été dégradé, on a perdu en moyenne la
moitié de notre matière organique. On va
pas la remonter en claquant des doigts.
Et donc là [grognement] maintenant qu'il
y a plus d'engrais, plus de pesticid et
qu'on dépend du pétrole maintenant pour
les gens, au lieu de dépendre de la
photosynthèse, on n'est pas bien. Lydia,
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ? On est
vraiment dans le mur et et quels sont
les risques que notre société française,
notre pilier qui est l'agriculture est
en train de prendre ?
Claude a déjà dit pas mal de choses
là-dessus, mais c'est vrai que si on a
une agriculture qui est complètement
perfusée et si nous n'avons plus la
possibilité des herbicides, des
pesticides et de et de même de ces
compléments pour maintenir une
agriculture
avec des rendements, et ben la
l'adéquation va vers des restrictions
automatiquement de de rendement et donc
pénurie de nourriture Et quand un peuple
a faim, bah c'est la guerre.
En France, on connaît bien le problème.
En 1789, on leur a expliqué une fois,
hein.
Voilà.
Et en plus, la veille de 1789, je crois
qu'il y a eu un énorme elnig. [soupir]
Là, il y a encore un énorme elnigho qui
est en train de se former. Claude, c'est
quoi Elnigho et quelles sont les
répercussions que ça peut avoir sur
l'agriculteur mondial ? Alors, est un
courant euh changement d'un courant qui
a lieu dans le Pacifique et qui va
changer complètement la climatologie
l'année où il a lieu. Et euh c'est vrai
que comme déjà le climat euh est
sérieusement perturbé, puisqu'on voit
qu'en France, on se dirige vers un
climat méditerranéen sur le nord du
pays, c'est-à-dire des hivers doux avec
beaucoup d'eau et puis après la
sécheresse derrière et le nignon
amplifie le phénomène. Mais c'est sûr
que là maintenant nous on est vigneron,
ça devient très compliqué de on sait pas
quelle année cette année par exemple on
sait pas si on va pouvoir produire du
raisin. Le Cli on a de la sécheresse là
depuis le depuis le mois de mars.
On dit que en avril l'orage d'avril
remplit les barils. Là on n pas une
goutte d'eau en avril donc les barils,
on va avoir du mal à les remplir. Et
tous les agriculteurs vivent dans cette
angoisse permanente. Comment sera
l'année ? Et là avec Elignho, ça va pas
ranger les choses.
Votre votre expérience tous les deux,
vous avez discuté avec des politiques
des partis politiques à l'Assemblée X ou
Y. C'était quoi leur question ? C'était
quoi leurs angoisses ? Et vous, comment
vous évaluez la gestion de la crise
alimentaire ? Parce que qui dit crise
énergétique dit forcément ensuite crise
alimentaire. votre perception de l'or
capacité à gérer la situation avec la
guerre, avec les engrais, avec les
pesticides, tout ce qui est à base de
pétrole ou de gaz, vous les sentez
comment ? Ils sont bien, ils sont pas
bien ? Ils sont connectés avec la
réalité ? Comment ça se passe ?
Qui commence Lydia ?
Non, je pense pas qu'il soit connecté de
la réalité. Et en plus nous quand on
nous on a on nous a demandé de d'aller à
une réunion sur les problèmes de
l'agriculture, la guerre en Iran n'avait
pas commencé. Donc le problème du de la
fermeture de du golf
ou
du D3, elle était pas présente.
Mais ils sont c'est des gens enfin nous
on moi je on enfin on est sorti tous les
deux peut-être mais complètement euh bah
ils sont complètement déconnectés du
problème de bah de cette de cette crise
alimentaire parce que elle elle existait
déjà nous en je dirais sousachante
sousjachante pardon avant le avant cette
guerre en Iran. Il y a eu déjà des
problèmes avec la guerre en Ukraine,
avec le problème de céréales, la
l'approvisionnement des céréales. Et en
fait, ils sont complètement déconnectés.
Ils demandent des solutions mais en fait
quelque part, ils sont absolument pas
prêts à les entendre. Euh c'est toujours
ben mais avec vos techniques là de
d'agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement des sols, on ne pourra
pas nourrir la planète euh ou
[grognement]
mais ça c'est c'est pas durable. Il faut
absolument qu'on utilise des pesticides
euh et des engrais parce que en fait on
aura pas grandement et quand on leur dit
"Mais les sols sont dans un tel état et
que plus on plus on va dans ce sens-là,
plus on on va la tête dans le mur quoi."
Et moi, je suis tout ce qu'on leur a
proposé, ils étaient complètement
éberlués en disant "Mais est-ce que
c'est possible ? Est-ce que c'est pas
possible
Claude
oui, je crois qu'il ils comprennent pas
ils comprennent pas ce qui est en train
de se passer. Non seulement il y a ce
problème, on a on a basé tout sur le
pétrole et là on a une crise pétrolière,
une crise énergétique donc c'est très
embêtant pour l'agriculture. Mais il y a
aussi politiquement une chose qui a moi
quand j'ai fait la gros expliquait que
les États-Unis avait fait un plan, un
green un plan vert pour être les
premiers producteurs mondiaux de de blé
pour tenir la planète. à l'époque, il
faisait 65 millions de tonnes de blé. À
l'heure actuelle, les américains ne font
plus que 45 millions de tonnes.
Attention hein, c'est énorme. Et pendant
ce temps-là, la Russie qu'on nourrissait
est devenu premier producteur mondial de
blé avec 80 millions de tonnes et
l'Ukraine, le deuxè devant les
États-Unis avec 50 millions de tonnes.
C'est-à-dire que le jeu de Poutine,
c'est quoi ? Il veut faire voilà, il
veut serrer l'Occident et le les tenir
bien serrés. Et comment on fait pour
répondre à ça ? C'est trop tard. C'est
trop tard. On a on a esquinté nos sols,
on a on a fait des variétés de blé qui
sont pas de qualité. Donc on se fait
prendre tous les marchés comme les
marchés égyptiens, parukrainien et les
Russe. Donc on est parti dans un truc
complètement délirant sans regarder la
réalité quoi. La réalité qui est que
c'est fini. L'Europe est devenue le
premier importateur mondial d'aliments.
Elle n'a plus de sécurité alimentaire
donc elle dépend de poutine. Comment on
va faire ? ou des États-Unis
ou des États-Unis mais pas pour le blé
hein
Oui. Elle ne dépend pas que de Elle elle
ne dépend pas que de Poutine. Regarde
bon ce qui se passe avec l'Iran. Euh euh
ben ça dépend aussi de bah de tous les
pays qui sont en crise. On est euh la
planète est loin d'être dans la paix
hein. Les guerres sont toujours très
souvent liées à des problèmes de de
nourriture, hein. On dit que c'estie.
Ouais. Bon, on dit que c'est des
problèmes politiques mais très souvent
c'est ça et ça c'est effectivement
une population qui ne peut pas se
nourrir, c'est un vrai problème. Oui,
c'est vraiment un problème. Et je trouve
que nous ça fait quand même 30 oui
presque 40 ans en fait ce problème bon
qui n'était pas à ce point-là et là les
choses s'accélèrent vraiment. On sent
que il y a Oui, c'est c'est on est très
très proche du mur. Nous quand on a
commencé, on a dit que si on pensait et
on l'a vu puisqu'on a travaillé dans le
monde que en fait le la base de tout
c'est c'est les c'est les sols pour
nous. Et bon
la qualité des sols et plus on a plus on
avance et en fait les et ben moins les
sols sont capables de produire
bah des céréales, de l'alimentation sans
leur perfusion. Et si on en a plus, ça
sera la c'est une crise énorme. Les gens
ne sont absolument pas conscients du
problème que il est en train de se
passer. Pas du tout. Je crois qu'ils
sont dans un déis. Cloud
c'est
le sol d'ailleurs le mot humus a donné
le mot homme le mot humanité c'est comme
dit Lidia c'est la base de tout à partir
du moment où on a décidé que ce n'était
plus la source alimentaire de l'humanité
mais simplement un support sur lequel on
balance des engrais des pesticides cette
cette ce concept du sol totalement
délirant qui est purement technique et
qui est absolument pas scientifique et
qui comprend pas le fonctionnement du
sol et ben on on dépend de bon donc on a
besoin de 10 calories de pétrole pour
faire une calorie alimentaire et en hors
sol c'est 36 calories de pétrole pour
faire une calorie de tomate. Maintenant
s'il y a plus de pétrole comment on fait
pour les gens ? Donc on est dans une
situation qui est très intéressante,
c'est qu'avec ces engrais, on a
multiplié la population mondiale. On est
bientôt 8 milliards, mais ils vivent
tous du pétrole. Ils sont nourris par le
pétrole. Si le pétrole chute, comment on
nourrit 8 milliards d'habitants sur une
planète ? On a à peu près un hectar 6
chacun pour s'habiller, se loger, se
nourrir et cetera. C'est pas lourd un
hectar 6. Nous, on a besoin de on a
besoin juste pour manger de 6000 m² et
il y a à peu près à peu près 2000 m² de
terre cultivée par habitant. Donc on est
une situation qui est quand même
compliquée et on a on a fait le le
système le déni sing
mais maintenant on commence à être la
situation va être de plus en plus
tendue.
Les préconisations vous allez que vous
leur avez chuchoté à l'oreille ça
ressemblait à quoi ?
Bah déjà, on leur avait dit par rapport
à à l'Europe, pourquoi la France,
bah les les lycées, les collèges
agricoles, l'instruction agricole
faisait partie du ministère de
l'agriculture alors que dans les pays
d'Europe et bien en fait ça fait partie
du ministère de de l'éducation nationale
et en fait ils ont pas compris mais les
ministères de l'agriculture en fait ils
sont plus que fagocités ou euh bloqués
par les multinationales par ça. Donc de
toute façon, il y a pas il y a pas de
liberté dans le ministère de
l'agriculture. Moi, je me souviens quand
on donnait des cours, une jeune femme
qui disait "Mais quand on on fait le
programme, en fait, il y a il y a un
représentant du ministre de
l'agriculture, il y a un représentant de
la FNSEA, il y a il y a et en fait le
proviseur n'a même pas le choix de de
des sujets qu'on va faire parce qu'en
fait c'est complètement
Oui. pris par
ça. Alors que dans le ministère de
l'éducation nationale, d'abord, je pense
que le le le les gens ou les fils
d'agriculteurs comptoir pourraient
contoyer d'autres personnes et voir
autre chose que bah cette agriculture
qu'on le qu'on leur dit. Ils sont il y a
des agriculteurs qui disent ben on a le
packaging, on n même pas besoin de
réfléchir à ce qu'on va faire. Vous
faites c, vous faites ça comme ça et ça
ça les a choqué en disant bon on est
l'exception mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire l'exception ? Il y a la France et
voilà.
Claude
toi tu en as une
Ouais, on leur a expliqué que il fait ça
fait quand même plus de 20 ans qu'on
leur explique qu'il faut arrêter le
labour, qu'il faut pratiquer ce qu'on
appelle le semidirect sous couvert à ne
jamais laisser le sol nu. faire des
couverts. Ces couverts peuvent être soit
utilisés par le béta, soit simplement
pour restaurer la matière organique dans
les sols. Il y a aucune aucune étude
correcte qui soit faite sur le plan
scientifique. C'est-à-dire que les
agricoles qui créent qui font du SMIRX
sous couvert, ils le font eux-mêmes.
Donc il manqu scientifique, de support
de recherche qui leur permettrait
d'aller plus vite, de reconstituer les
stocks de matière organique dans leur
sol parce que évidemment l'agroindustrie
veut pas entendre parler. Nous le
premier agriculteur qu'on a amené au
semidirect, un gars qui est près de 3,
il était à 1,4 % de matière organique en
2000, il est maintenant 4,6, il ne
consomme plus de potasse, utilise plus
de phosphore. Il a divisé par deux ces
doses d'azote. Ça n'intéresse pas la
grande industrie, il n'irrigue plus
parce que ses maïs descendent en
profondeur. Donc l'agroindustrie, il a
plus besoin de gros tracteur puisqu'il
abour plus. Donc je veux dire toute
l'agroindustrie ne veut pas entendre
parler de techniques respectueuses des
sols parce que il ils vont plus faire de
business. Donc c'est très compliqué. Il
bloque il bloque l'évolution et il faut
que les agriculteurs de demain soient
des scientifiques et connaissent
réellement comment fonctionne un sol,
comment qu'est-ce que c'est que la
physiologie végétale ? Qu'est-ce et ça
ils le savent pas.
Quelles autres préconisations vous leur
avez offert et quel quelle a été sa leur
réaction ?
Alors, ils étaient contents de vous voir
parce que ça leur faisait une petite
après-midi tranquille, ça parlait de la
campagne ou ils étaient inquiets par
rapport Non, je crois pas. Il était
content de nous voir. Je pense que
peut-être qu'il voulait mais moi j'ai
pas peut-être la personne qui nous a
fait venir parce qu'elle nous suit et
c'est elle qui a dû insister mais tous
les autres étaient je avais je pour moi
je trouve une position déjà absolument
négative. C'est-à-dire que dès qu'on
disait quelque chose, en fait, c'était
pas possible. quand on parlait de d'une
agriculture en respectant que les sols
en fait ne plus les prendre comme un
support et quand un sol est vivant ben
on a besoin de beaucoup moins de produit
de fertilisant de il y a moins de
maladie et en plus l'alimentation a plus
de euh oui est plus pas calorique mais a
plus de nutriments et elle est aussi
plus énergétique. On est on ne mange pas
que des calories hein. La nourriture,
c'est aussi une forme d'énergie et là
c'est on ne peut pas avec vos
techniques, on peut pas nourrir on peut
pas nourrir l'humanité. Donc c'est c'est
tout de suite un barrage.
Il y a un si je dois admettons qu'on ait
du temps, chose qui nous manque, mais
reconstituer les sols, faire un sevrage
de nos sols par rapport à tout ce qu'on
leur met dans la tête comme engrais
comme comme tout ça, il faut combien de
temps ? Ça crée un trou d'air de combien
de temps ? Mais ça dépend de
ça dépend de comment ça a été géré et
puis quel type de sol vous avez. Les
gens pensent que les sols sont tous
identiques mais c'est pas vrai. Vous
avez des sols qui vont être plus à bleu
qui ont de l'argile ou des limons. Donc
déjà la constitution du sol est
différente. Donc vous pourrez pas le le
le retour à la normale va être différent
en fonction de ça. Les cultures vont
vont être adaptées. Donc il y a ça peut
aller dans certains cas quand tout va
bien bah en 5 ans, on peut remettre un
sol debout. C'est pas si c'est pas si
long que ça. Mais par contre quand vous
êtes sur les gens qui font des patates
ou qui font de la betterave, c'est une
culture qui est extrêmement
invasive sur les sols et nous et là
c'est pas vraiment une bonne nouvelle
mais on a des sols ça fait 15 ans qu'on
travaille et en fait ils ne retrouvent
pas parce que en fait on ils sont
toujours dans une culture comme ils font
pas de rotation et qui font ou quasiment
pas de rotation et bien en fait si on
fait presque tout le temps de la pomme
de terre le sol il peut pas il peut peut
pas récupérer, il peut pas guérir de de
ce qu'on lui a fait avant. Donc en fait,
il y a tout ça, c'est remettre un sol
debout, c'est aussi le contexte de
l'agriculteur. Qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire ? Est-ce qu'il acceptera de faire
des rotations ? Est-ce qu'il aura
croit
est-ce qu'il y croit ? C'est ça
Cloude.
Ben le si on prend par exemple le
passage du labour au semi direct,
pendant 5 ans, il y a une chute de
rendement. Donc si l'État n'aide pas
l'agriculteur pendant ces 5 années pour
qu'il puisse restaurer en fait il faut
recapitaliser. Donc quand on a
décapitalisé [raclement de gorge]
on dépense de l'argent pour
recapitaliser. Donc si l'État veut pas
faire ça net pas les gars, ils se
lanceront pas là-dedans. Ils diront non.
Pareil pour la bio. Donc le problème
c'est que si on n'aide pas les
agriculteurs à s'occuper du patrimoine
qui est un patrimoine national, il est
privé mais en fait il est national, bah
les choses les choses vont pas bouger.
Et là pour le moment euh on n'est pas
parti pour. Je sais pas si on y
arrivera, j'espère mais pour le moment
on n'est pas parti pour. La la FNS
freine des cas de fer, l'agroindustrie
freine des cas de fer. Donc c'est pas
facile de faire bouger le système.
Mais le problème de le problème des
subventions c'est pareil. Là, on a on a
on a été confronté à à des choses par
une députée qui disait "Mais vous rendez
compte parce que on avait les les l'idée
de dire bon le volume d'argent, toutes
les subventions qui sont données par
l'Europe au aux agriculteurs, on disait
bah à ce moment-là chaque agriculteur a
une importance. C'est pas parce que vous
faites 2 hectares de maréchage qui
demande certainement autant de travail
et que vous avez 100 hectares de
céréales, on était pour dire bah il y a
une fa d'égalité, c'est-à-dire qu'on va
partager
ces ces subventions pour chacun puisque
le travail peut-être que et en
production un maréché quelque part
produit plusieurs fois presque autant
qu'un seralier si on regarde dans son et
la la personne une députée a me dit mais
vous rendez compte de ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire mais c'est
absolument pas faisable. Et on lui dit
"Mais pourquoi c'est pas faisable ? Il y
a une l'agriculture, elle nourrit, on
mange des légumes, on mange du pain et
tout." Elle dit "Mais mais vous vous
rendez compte pour les gros pour les
gros agriculteurs, comment ça va se
passer ?" Et je lui dis "Mais elle pé
elle dit ben par exemple pour pour nous"
et je lui dis "Mais vous avez combien
d'hectares ?" Et elle a jamais voulu
répondre. et elle a dit "Mais vous
rendez compte, si on a plus de
subvention, mais on n'y arrivera plus,
on ne pourra plus, on ira pas jusqu'au
bout." Alors que les petits euh ce n'y
arrive pas se se pendre, se suicide.
C'est quand on entend ça, vous pouvez
ressortir qu'en étant complètement ben
dépité de dire on n'est pas prêt et puis
quand on a dit que l'histoire des 5 ans,
le temps de la reconversion, il faudrait
que les ces agriculteurs qui font quand
même un effort pour avoir qu'on ait une
une nourriture de meilleure qualité ne
perdent pas de salaire, soit pas à la
limite, on va dire subventionné, mais
qu'en fait ils aient au moins le la même
le même revenu plutôt que de les laisser
avec une chute de rendement. Et euh et
pour la première fois l'année dernière,
on a eu un retour d'agriculteurs en
biologie qui repassent en conventionnel,
qui réutilise des produits. C'est pas ça
l'avenir.
Si on prend une chose toute simple, on
prend les 9 milliards de d'euros que
touche la France pour 300000
agriculteurs, ça fait 30000 € par
agriculteur. donner 30000 € à Grite, je
pouris vous dire qu'il y a des jeunes
qui vont sortir de la ville et qui vont
vous faire du maréchage parce qu'ils
toucheront 30000 € et là vous allez
donner à manger au français mais ça veut
dire que le prix de la FNSA qui a 700
hectares qui touche 140000 € lui
touchera plus que 30000 donc lui il va
pas être content il fera présence sur le
gouvernement pour que surtout on ne
répartisse pas cette somme. Mais c'est
ce qu'elle a dit cette cette député,
c'était c'était sous-entendu en disant
"Moi, il me faut il me faut ma
subvention de plusieurs millions."
D'autres préconisations que vous leur
avez distylé concernant la robustesse de
notre système agricole, la robustesse de
nos terres, la robustesse de nos
paysages.
Ils sont restés avec des yeux
écarquillés, ils vous ont suivi, ils
vous ont donné une carte de visite pour
p rester en contact. Comment ça se passe
?
Ah non, je pense qu'on a pas eu de carte
de visite et on n pas eu du tout de
nouvelles de ce cet entretien. Mais il y
a 4 ans, il nous avait déjà fait venir
et on a toujours on avait pas eu de
nouvell, on n' pas vu de changement
parce que moi je je trouve que en fait
il y a eu un il y a eu un petit virage
je trouve dans les années 2010 où en
fait on avait l'impression que euh les
choses étaient en train de de se
débloquer, qu'on comprenait il y avait
de du semi bah des agriculteurs en
semiirect, on voyait arriver plus
d'agriculteurs en bio Et là, je trouve
que on est presque un retour en arrière
puisque euh
il était question par exemple l'histoire
du glyphosate, on a complètement arrêté
puisqu'on est reparti pour 30 ans hein,
en 2030, on ramène des néonicotïdes.
Pour nous, c'est un on fait un recul.
Donc
je ben et ben il y a pas il y a pas de
réponse. Donc je pense tout à l'heure
vous disiez mais on est gênant, on est
extrêmement gênant pour le pour les
multinationales.
C'est pour ça qu'on vous attaque vous
les pieniques qui dansent sous la lune,
qui plantent avec la lune, les
picniques. sûr parce que déjà euh on on
fait comprendre que et qu'on a
complètement oublié que les sol a une
vocation. C'est-à-dire plus vous vous
approchez de la vocation de votre sol,
si c'est un sol pour faire des céréales,
vous allez utiliser moins de produits,
vous allez utiliser moins de fertilisant
parce qu'en fait c'est un sol
naturellement dans son climax, il va
faire des cérales ou de la famille des
cérales, on va dire sauvages. Donc en
fait, on est en adéquation avec son sol,
donc on va moins avoir besoin. Et dans
tout ce qu'a décrit Claude ou ce qu'on
décrit, en fait c'est un manque à gagner
pour ces multinationales. quand on fait
du semiirect, on va bah com consommer
beaucoup moins de fiou avec les
problèmes de fioules, mais euh les
tracteurs donc en fait on est combattu
tout le temps parce que on veut on n'est
pas dans un système de défaire dépenser
de l'argent. On est dans un système où
en fait on réenrichit un patrimoine. On
ne détruit pas le patrimoine, ne le
réenrichit. On va rendre euh c'était un
peu un dicton, les paysans devaient
rendre une terre aussi fertile que à
leurs enfants. Et bien nous, c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire.
Cloue ?
Alors ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
ils nous ont demandé les députés qu'il
fallait retrouver la sécurité
alimentaire de la France, euh on leur a
répondu "Mais attendez, nous avons perdu
96 % de nos paysans depuis 1950. 96 % de
nos paysans ont disparu. Vous croyez
qu'avec les 4 % qui restent, vous allez
pouvoir nourrir les 70 millions de
français ? Mais c'est totalement
impossible. Si vous voulez refaire
arrêter d'importer 77 % de nos fruits et
légumes, arrêtez d'importer la moitié de
notre viande, il faut qu'il y ait des
hommes et ces hommes, vous allez les
trouver comment ? Où ?
Quel savoir ? Quelle transmission ?
Quelle transmission ? Quel savoir ?
Comment vous allez faire pour remettre ?
Les jeunes veulent plus travailler à la
terre. Nous on le voit bien, on est
vigneron pour trouver quelqu'un pour
vendanger. Les jeunes, ils veulent pas.
Ils ne veulent pas. Ils veulent
Tu les payes tes vangers ?
Comment
tu les payes tes vents ?
Oui, on les paye les vangers mais on est
obligé d'aller chercher des bulgares,
des Roumains parce que les Français
veulent pas. Donc il y a quand même un
vrai problème. Donc comment on va
comment on va nourrir les Français s'il
y a plus de paysans ? Donc on a laissé
partir en se disant mais non maintenant
il y a de l'industrie, on a du pétrole
donc on a plus besoin de paysan mais je
crois qu'on a commis une énorme erreur.
On a besoin de paysans pour faire le
pays.
Bien sûr.
Bon tous les trois on va faire une
expérience de pensée. On va fusionner
nous notre veille géopolitique
géostratégique de guerre économique et
votre expérience des sols.
Messieurs dames, j'ai un gros problème.
J'ai l'Iran qui bloque un peu. J'ai
Trump qui nous met des colliers, des
laisses un peu partout.
qui nous met aussi des laisses sur le
vivant avec des brevets sur des semences
qui nous met des tarifs sur certaines
choses. Moi français, j'ai besoin de
deux vieux. Excusez-moi de vous dire que
vous êtes vieux mais
oui. [rires]
Donc j'ai besoin de de vieux. Je vois
notre renseignement, notre stratégie,
notre anticipation.
nager, boire à la tasse toutes les deux
minutes à rien anticiper, à se prendre
des vagues dans la tête alors que
c'était cousu de fil blanc. Là, ça
touche les rateliers. Quand il n'y a
plus de foin dans les rateliers, les
chevaux se battent. Quelle préconisation
vous pouvez donner à notre communauté
pour faire un peu de calories sur leur
balcon, sur leur jardin pour améliorer
le beurre dans les épinards ?
Alors ben faire comme ils font à Cuba
cultiv même dans les gouttières,
cultivent même dans leur gouttières.
Donc ils arrivent à à prodier. On oublie
une chose hein, c'est que un maréché du
moyen du du 19e siècle produisait 10
fois plus au mètre carré qu'un maréché
moderne parce que il faisait neuf
cultures par an alors qu'on en fait plus
que deux maintenant. Donc il y avait il
y avait une véritable connaissance de
des rotations de des associations qui a
été complètement disparues. Mais nous on
a travaillé à Cuba. C'est impressionnant
de voir comment ce peuple qui est quand
même bloqué depuis 70 ans, qui a plus
droit à rien, qui comment il arrive à
résister, c'est moi je je leur dis
chapeau parce que vivre comme ça en
étant privé de tout commerce, bah ils
arrivent à cultiver, à faire des
rotations à faire des des associations
incroyables de légumes au même endroit
et ils arrivent à manger. Je dis pas que
c'est passionnant hein, c'est la vie est
dure à Cuba mais il meurt pas. On a
enfin je suis je suis désolé mais il y a
beaucoup moins que de bid s'armé dans
les gares à Cuba que en France he qu'à
Paris hein. C'est donc le alors je je
dis pas que c'est c'est idéal mais enf
ils produisent quand même plus de miel
que la France sur une surface bien plus
petite parce que eux comme ils ont plus
droit aux pesticides plus droit aux
engrais chimiques, bah ils ont une
activité biologique qui est
intéressante. Donc ils ont plein
d'abeilles. Nous on en a plus parce
qu'on les a tué à coup de pesticide.
Donc je pense qu'on peut si on veut
faire revivre tout ça il faut repartir
de là. Mais on a perdu toute la
biodiversité s'effondre. On a perdu
entre 70 et 90 % des représentants des
familles que ce soit les verrs de terre,
les les colembols, les acariens, les
oiseaux, les insectes, tous s fondent.
Là-bas, il y a encore ça chante encore
dans les campagnes, il y a encore de la
il y a encore de la vie quoi. Nous euh
on n'est pas bien hein. Ça va être long
à redresser
Lydia à l'échelle nationale autre que
faire des petits potagers sur les
balcons avec tes quatre tomates en fin
de saison à l'échelle nationale si tu
avais des des recommandations, des
préconisations ou même des ordres à leur
donner parce que maintenant il faut
arrêter de leur donner des conseils, il
faut leur donner des ordres. Il je pense
qu'ils comprennent que le baton à mon
avis, non ? Petit coup de fourche. Non.
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que tu en penses
? Tu crois que ça ça va se matérialiser
dans les rues avec les fourches qui vont
sortir comme dans notre histoire ?
Ben écoute, il y a eu des je dirais il y
a eu des fourches qui sont sorties,
hein. Les agriculteurs sont sortis il y
a pas si longtemps, hein. Euh la
préconisation euh
[grognement]
bah ce serait déjà de
bah de s'occuper de des sols, essayer de
de repartir sur des vocations de sol,
hein, de de d'être plus en oui, en
adéquation avec son sol. Et euh
dans les écoles d'apprentissage
peut-être ?
Oui, mais dans les écoles de toute
façon, c'est pas des choses qui sont
enseignées. Là, euh il y a un gros
problème dans d'enseignement. Nous quand
on a on pouvait enseigner puisque on a
plus le droit d'enseigner puisque on est
gênant au niveau de depuis l'affaire où
on nous a on nous a collé de le fait
queon on était
membre du du Front National en 2017 euh
et on a été c'est le c'est un syndicat
de de
comment euh de d'école, je vais y
arriver, qui en fait a fait courir le
bruit que on était du Front National au
moment de en 2017 au moment de des
élections, les futures élections et on
devait le
monsieur Lefol, ministre de
l'agriculture nous avait demandé de
dispenser un cours qui aurait été filmé
dans différentes on coupe la la France
en quatre, l'est, le sud-ouest, le
nord-est le
le nord-ouest, le sud-ouest, le nord-est
et le sud-est. Et en fait,
ben ce syndicat
a dit que on faisait du Front National
et ça a été supprimé et on a interdit
d'enseignement, enfin c'est pas écrit
sur le papier, mais depuis ce jour-là
aucun on a plus on ne donne plus aucun
cours dans aucun lycée, dans collège
agricole. On est complètement euh
interdit et on la rend quand on quand on
tu as reçu avec ton homme derrière, on a
pris des réflexion comme quoi vous étiez
extrême droite, des piques hallucinés et
ainsi de suite.
Mais moi, il faut pas faut pas me dire
ça à moi parce que la première chose
[rires]
c'est que je vous réinvite tout de
suite. On invite qui on veut, on discute
avec qui on veut. Si on pense qu'il y a
des choses intéressantes à prendre, on
prend. Mais est-ce que je peux me
permettre de dire quelque chose même à
la limite
si même si je veux dire on on avait ce
parti qui est euh hein euh et je pense
que dans le dans les écoles où on était,
il y avait certainement des parents qui
étaient euh du centre de ce qu'on voudra
mais la politique n'a rien à voir avec
l'alimentation humaine. Absolument rien
à voir. pouvait être pour pour ou contre
nourrir nourrir un peuple, ça
n'appartient pas à la politique. La
politique est en train de de détruire ça
et je trouve que nous empêcher
parce queon a une identité politique qui
ne plaît pas de donner un discours qui
est suputé
ou en plus parce que c'est peut-être pas
le cas loin de là.
C'est empêcher en fait des enfants et
des des adolescents et des futurs
agriculteurs ou de gens qui de penser et
de se dire il y a il y a plusieurs
possibilités parce qu'on parle du
semidirect de secouvert, on parlait de
la permaculture, on parlait de méthode
pour pouvoir valoriser au maximum un
lanter et essayer de petit à petit de
diminuer les intr au lendemain de les
accompagner dans leur dans leur leur
gestion du jour au lendemain, on a on
dit bah non parce que ils ont cette
étiquette mais c'est lamentable, c'est
absolument inacceptable à notre époque
de d'empêcher un savoir parce que alors
qu'on faisait pas de politique
l'agriculture enfin même si même bah si
c'est devenu un problème politique,
c'est devenu un problème politique. Ça
va le devenir grandement d'ailleurs
parce que quand on regarde les
fondamentaux là, je me demande comment
ils vont faire. Claude euh comment tu
vois la situation évoluer avec l'Iran,
la Russie, l'Ukraine, euh le Mercosour,
le Brésil et tout ça ? Ce ce pot pourri
que va devenir notre France ? Ben nous,
ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on par
exemple, je vais prendre l'histoire de
la betterave, euh
le plus gros producteur de sucre de
France a vendu ses parts euh à l'hectare
aux betterraaviers français. On on leur
avait dit à l'époque faites attention,
ils sont en train de construire la plus
grosse sucrerie du monde au Brésil.
S'ils font de l'épart, c'est pour
pouvoir financer leur truc là-bas. Bah
les betterraavés, ils ont payé leur ils
ont payé ils ont vendu le enfin ils ont
acheté ces ces ces parl et maintenant
évidemment parce que je peux dire
qu'avec le mercour les premiers qui vont
trinquer, c'est les gros métraviers hein
parce que le à l'heure actuelle au
Brésil on en est à 30 tonnes de sucre à
l'hctare alors qu'on est qu'à entre les
meilleurs font 18 tonnes en France. Donc
avec une consommation de fou bien plus
importante pour produire le sucre de
betterave que le sucre de canne. Donc la
situation elle est elle va se passer
très mal. les les Brésiliens en train de
de continuer à buter la forêt, à la
détruire. Ils vont bientôt arriver sur
l'Amazone. Quand ils seront sur
l'Amazone, il y aura des barges de
500000 tonnes qui apporteront le soja,
le tournesol, le la canne à sucre, les
poulets, la viande directement en face
de l'Europe. Donc je sais pas comment
l'Europe va va tenir le coup. Je
souviens en 2000 euh Lydia Lydia avait
organisé avec 10 gros séréaliers
français un voyage au Brésil pour qu'il
voit un peu. Alors il y avait un
bosseron qui cranait pendant tout le
voyage nous emmerdait qui était le plus
gros, le plus beau. Il avait 500
hectares et cetera et on arrive à on
arrive il y avait un breton, il y avait
un grade laquite. On avait pris
différentes régions de France. On arrive
à
dans le sud du Brésil et on sort de
l'aéroport et qu'est-ce qu'on voit d'où
? une énorme usine avec écrit doux.
Alors, il y a le Breton qui dit "Ah,
c'est marrant, c'est le même nom que
notre usine de poulet en Bretagne." Non,
mais je dis c'est monsieur Dou qui a
compris qu'il valait mieux transporter
des poulets vers la France avec le soja
aux portes de l'usine que de transporter
que de faire venir du soja et nourrir
des poulets en Bretagne. Et bien, Dou a
reçu une subvention du gouvernement
français pour installer son usine au
Brésil et maintenant bah l'élevage la
France importe la moitié de ses poulets
parce capable de nourrir les Français.
Donc on a vu, on a montré aux gens alors
c'é amusant parce que le premier qui
nous reçoit, le premier paysan qui nous
reçoit brésilien, il dit "Je m'excuse,
je suis une petite entre je suis un
petit céralé, j'ai que 900 hectares."
Donc on voit le on voit le bosseron qui
cramenait pendant le voyage devenir tout
blanc parce que là effectivement il
faisait pas le poids. Et on a terminé
sur le nord du enfin le front pionnier
amazonien avec des gars qui avaient
entre 30000 et 50000 hectares. Donc là
les gars quand ils étaient partis pris
l'avion, il pensaiit qu'il éit tombé sur
des gars avec des matches qui coupaient
de la canne à sucre.
José quoi.
Voilà c'est José. Voilà c'est Rosé qui
coupe. Ils sont tombés sur des gars qui
étaient connectés directement avec la
banque de Chicago pour savoir combien
ils allaient est alors il y en a 20 qui
nous avaient dit non cette année l'an
dernier je fais 4000 hectares de soja
mais cette année ça ça paye plus je vais
en faire 10000 donc les autres ils
étaient et donc on on leur montrait que
c'était pas du tout ce qu'on leur
montrait de du Brésil. C'était pas un
pays sous-développé, c'était en train de
devenir une grosse puissance agricole
mais ils y croyaient pas. Ils y ils
pensaient pas que c'était ça. Donc en
fait la France c'est un pays qui est
assez unique. C'est le seul c'est le
avec Madagascar le pays qui a la
géologie la plus complexe du monde.
C'est que nous avons tous les sols de la
planète des climats méditerranéens,
climats atlantiques, climats des
montagnes jeunes, des montagnes
anciennes. Donc la France est un pays de
terroir. C'est un pays qui aurait dû
miser sur la qualité. Qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait après guerre ? On a tout détruit.
On a détruit nos variétés de pommes, nos
variétés de légumes, nos on ne cultive
plus de variétés de blé français. C'est
que des clones. Il y a plus de culture
de quand les gens quand un agrit vous
dit tiens, j'ai telle variété de pommes.
Non, c'est un clone. Il y a plus de
variété. Il y a que des clones. Là en
vigne, c'est que des clones. Donc on a
cassé un modèle extraordinaire que les
anciens avaient fait. D'ailleurs, on on
parlait de la la pomme du Ment du du
port de Paris. Le port de Paris est
éteint, ça a disparu. Donc on a on a
détruit quelque chose qui était
extraordinaire. La France aurait dû être
le jardin du monde et on devrait
exporter sur toute la planète et là
maintenant on est des importateurs. En
fait donc c'est un échec total de la
politique agricole française depuis la
guerre.
H
39 45
39 45 plan marchal
américain.
Ouais tiens standardisation.
Oui, exactement. Euh là, la guerre avec
les Russes, ça a pas l'air de
s'arranger. La guerre avec les Iraniens,
ça a pas l'air de s'arranger.
Puis on va dire les mots, on est aussi
en guerre avec les États-Unis.
Ouais.
Oui, bien sûr.
Mais on veut pas le dire
parce que les gars femmes, les le les
taxes douanières, les menaces et je on
veux dire voilà,
tu vois le truc comment ? C'est-à-dire
que si les Américains nous vendent des
graines breuftetées ou des engrais
breuftetés ou n'importe quoi breufteté,
on voit comment ils nous mettent déjà la
pression avec les yafas.
On voit comment ils y mettent la
pression avec les gaz de chiste. Genre
fais pas trop ton malin Emmanuel parce
que là on va diminuer
l'approvisionnement. On voit comment
Poutine est tendu avec nous. H
on voit comment ramenai ou du moins ce
qu'il en reste c'est tendu.
Tu vois la France comment avec sa
robustesse atteinte ?
On en est où si on a plus les engrais ?
Si on a plus les pesticides, si on a
plus la chimie ? On en est où ? On est
capable de nourrir combien de personnes
sans tout ça ?
Alors ça, je sais pas combien de
Français on pourrait nourrir
dans l'état actuel. Je pose la la
question différemment. La balance
commerciale est déficitaire de combien
en France cette année ?
Ah je sais pas. Je sais en tout cas que
la balance commerciale de l'agriculture
est totalement déficit alors que nous
sommes le premier pays agricole
d'Europe. Un échec total.
Ils l'ont annoncé
quand il y a il y a il y a
l'organisation. Je crois que c'est le
pas l'OMC mais j'ai un truc de mor. Je
demande à me faire fa checker par la
communauté.
Un organisme d'échelle mondiale prévient
que on va avoir des pénuries
alimentaires.
Ça va se matérialiser au départ dans les
pays du tiersmonde. Comment ça ça se
matérialise toujours.
Bah oui. [raclement de gorge]
Puis ça va bouger. Les gens vont avoir
faim, vont vouloir trouver des routes
migratoires qui leur permettent un
avenir plus clément.
Tu vois, tu vois la France dans quel
état d'ici 5 ans Claude ? Tu nous vois
appliquer tes méthodes, tu les vois
toujours courir derrière le baril de
pétrole pour donner à manger. Tu leur
vois toujours nous compter des belles
paroles pour nous faire tenir. Et les
frigos qui se vident de plus en plus où
les gens mangent de moins en moins bien
ou tout en même temps.
Je sais pas moi, je vais prendre juste
la la chose où nous travaillons qui est
la vigne. On a réussi à détruire la
seule filière vraiment qui rapportait de
l'argent à la France. en racontant que
des des abrutis qui vous racontent que
dès le premier verre de vin, vous chopez
le cancer. Donc l'aconsommation c'est
totalement effondrée de 70 %.
Donc ça arrache massivement, la France
arrache massivement de la vigne et tout.
Donc
ils sont passés sur la bière hein.
Et ils sont passés sur la bière et
whisky
et de la drogue.
Un whisky on faisait
et de la drogue. Voilà. Et de la drogue.
On buvait
et et du protoxyde d'azote.
Voilà. Et le gaz il la rend. On on
consommait on buvait 1 million de
bouteilles de whisky en 1960. La France
en consomme plus de 100 millions
maintenant. Donc hein.
Donc on a remplacé le vin euh la plus
hygiénique, la plus saine des boissons
disait pasteur par des alcools durs qui
sont pas recommandés du tout. D'autant
plus c'est partiement chimiqué comme
production.
Quoi qu'il arrive la consommation
d'alcool et d'uside pour la santé à
consommer avec modération.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais le vin est très
bon pour la santé. C'est bourré de ligo
élément pour en boire raisonnablement un
deux verres par jour. Mais c'est très
bon pour la chan parce que
nos grands-parents qui on vivait tous
les jours, je suis désolé mais il ils
vivent bien et ils ont pas chopé de
cancer. Les cancers ils apparaissent
maintenant chez les jeunes qui boivent
plus de vin. H
alors tu es pas médecin mais tu vois
plus de cancer chez les agriculteurs,
plus de maladit de Parkinson,
plus de saloperie comme ça ? Ah oui
oui bien sûr.
Parce que maintenant vous êtes plus tout
jeune. Vous avez des copains qui sont
plus tout jeunes non plus. qui meurt
même en ce moment
et qui meurt en ce moment
de cancer. Euh il y a il y a il y a des
recherches autour de tout ça ou pas du
tout ?
Le problème c'est que c'est
multifactoriel, c'est extraordinairement
compliqué scientifiquement [grognement]
pour déterminer quel facteur là on est
en train de découvrir que le camion
qu'il y a dans les phosphates bah ça
provoque des maladies graves, des
cancers. Bon, mais c'est tellement
compliqué, on pollue tellement la
planète que
[grognement]
le Parkinson a été reconnu comme maladie
de
euh comment
professionnelle chez les
professionnel, merci. Voilà, chez les
agriculteurs parce que il y en a de plus
en plus. Et euh
vous avez un regard positif ou négatif
sur l'Europe ? l'Europe,
la Pâque, les cotas,
l'Europe maman, l'Europe qui dirige.
Vous avez quel regard sur eux ? Bon, au
départ la Pâque, c'était pas si mauvais
que ça en fait. C'était quelque chose
pour aider pour aider les agriculteurs
et c'était une association je dirais de
d'agriculteurs. Le probl le progrème. Le
problème c'est que on a mis des gens qui
ne sont plus agriculteurs, qui sont des
financiers et donc on a on a
complètement
bah détruit ce bon le cette pâque. Elle
est plus du tout à la disposition de des
agriculteurs, elle est à la disposition
de des financiers qui veulent gagner des
parts sur sur les agriculteurs de tout
ça qui finit sur certains fonds de
retraite parce que la titrisation de
tout ça,
ça finit sur les les fonds de retraite
américains.
H
oui, tout à fait. Claude,
non mais au début c'était très bien vu.
On devait normalement protéger tout ce
qui était production agricole entre les
pays européen. C'était une sorte de
protection de notre agriculture et le
résultat d'ailleurs a tellement bien
marché qu'on s'est retrouvé des
excédents de beurre, de lait, de blé.
Donc ça montrait que ça marchait bien.
Donc après il fallait réguler ça bien
entendu. On l'a pas fait. On a décidé de
changer les règles et de donner une
subvention à l'hectare. Donc les gros on
beaucoup d'hectares, il il piquent tout.
Les petits ont rien et le résultat ben
voilà, on mange plus, on mange plus
parce que ça pas ça a été très mal géré
ce système-là.
Vous vers Caor, euh [raclement de gorge]
nous vers la Bourgogne,
on trouvera toujours quelque chose à
manger. On connaît les cutterux du coin,
nos paysans du coin. Tu dis non avec le
doigt.
Oui, je dis non parce que en fait Caor
est une euh il y a une telle déprise
agricole, 80 % du territoire euh de Cor
et dans la friche.
Donc je vois mal Cor se nourrir
de ses sols d'abord parce que les sols
ont été pas mal ruinés et que de toute
façon il y a quasiment pas de à part de
la vigne et encore il y en a pas il y en
a pas tant que ça euh
tous les cotaux quand vous traversez le
lote et bien en fait ce n'est que que
des friches que des des sols
complètement abandonnés et je ne pense
pas que les casurciens s'il arrivaient
des une crise plus grave que ça soit
vraiment très très à l'avantage au
niveau de de la nourriture, hein.
C'est quelle région de France qui est le
plus avantagé en cas de crise
alimentaire ?
Euh
je dirais les zones d'élevage parce que
c'est là que les sols ont quand même le
plus de matière organique. Donc c'est
c'est cela qu'on pourra le plus
facilement.
Mais on est dans des situations par je
prendre un exemple très simple les la
perte de la notion dont parlait Lydia de
vocation de sol. On arrive chez un un
éleveur, un jeune qui crâne et tout et
mais qui nous explique il a plein de
problèmes de mamite et de maladie sur
ses vaches laitières. On étudie le sol
et on lui dit mais c'est pas un sol pour
faire du lait, c'est un sol pour faire
de la viande. Et à ce là, il y a le
grand-père qui sort de la grange. Je
t'avais bien dit que c'était des bêtes
pour la viande, pas pour le lait. Donc
le gamin, il est ruiné parce qu'il a il
a il a pas fait le bon choix. Donc il
veut essayer de faire 10000 L de lait à
ses vaches sur un terrain qui est fait
pour faire de la viande. Donc ça veut
dire un terrain où il fait sec en été
parce que pour que la viande soit bonne,
il faut qu'il y ait des périodes de où
la bête se nourrit au printemps, elle
enraisse, elle maigrit en été, elle
engraisse en autole, elle maigrit en
hiver. Et c'est cette alternance
d'engraissement et de qui fait la viande
persillée qui rend la viande très bonne.
Mais quand vous avez une période de
sécheresse pour une vache laitière, elle
produit plus. Donc on leur a tellement
raconté qu'avec des engrais, des précis,
on fait n'importe quoi, n'importe où que
les pauvres, ils se plantent
complètement. Ils se plantent dans les
choix de dans leur choix agricole. C'est
sortent de l'école, ils veulent faire
des vaches à 10000 L. Mais tu as pas le
sol pour faire ça. Ça, on les prévient
pas. Donc on les emmène à la ruine tout
simplement. Ça c'est très embêtant. Vous
êtes connecté avec des agriculteurs qui
vous disent "Bon maintenant, il y en a
assez, on va arrêter, on va faire autre
chose ou où on va monter à Paris ?"
Non, je je sais pas. le le les
agriculteurs en fait euh comme c'est la
profession euh la plus vieille hein, la
moyenne d'âge est de 55 ans, donc en
fait l'agriculteur il va avoir un
discours plutôt au niveau de de de la
succession, c'est-à-dire que il
[grognement] donnera absolument pas
l'envie à sa succession de reprendre les
terres. Donc en fait ça pose un vrai
problème parce que 55 ans, c'est quand
même bon, ils peuvent encore travailler
encore un peu de temps mais si on
continue comme ça, on est déjà on a
perdu 95 % de nos agriculteurs, ça sera
de pire en pire. Et politiquement
parlant, moi je me pose des questions vu
comment comment les choses se se font.
Est-ce que les politiques ne veulent pas
en fait avoir un quota d'agriculteur,
un pourcentage, un quota d'agriculteur
qui sera en fait avec un un revenu et
qui euh qui qui feront ce que on voudra,
ce que demandera les politiques. Ils
sont pas du tout dans on n pas du tout
l'impression que il y a une volonté
politique de faire que ces agriculteurs
restent et
avec le Covid, on a vu quelque chose que
qu'on avait pas vu avant. Je pense que
les les gens fuyaient les grandes villes
et on a eu énormément de jeunes qui nous
ont demandé de ou qui avait déjà cette
vision de faire de la permaculture. On a
fait croire que la permaculture ça
allait être la solution pour tout en
maréchage mais c'est pas si facile que
ça. Et ça c'est très compliqué. C'est
comme le semi secouvet. On ne devient
pas permaculteur comme ça du jour au
lendemain. Et en [grognement] fait, on a
eu des jeunes qui sont qui nous ont
demandé et ben, on a acheté, on va
s'installer euh pour faire euh pour
faire de la permaculture. Ce ce
phénomène, il a eu euh pendant 2 3 ans
et là, bon, on a l'impression que ça
s'est arrêté parce que mais c'est vrai
qu'au moment du Covid, bah on n'avait
pas le droit de sortir. Peut-être que
les gens en ville étaient complètement
coincés et il se disait en campagne et
c'est vrai qu'en campagne on peut on
peut se nourrir, on peut avoir des
poules, on peut on peut vivre en
autharcie mais l'autre je trouve que
c'est plus le problème de la de la
succession c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
repreneur des fermes. C'est ça qui est
grave.
La paire de savoir inhérente à tout ça.
Claude, il y a il y a une bibliothèque
universaliste de toutes les techniques
de bitnic que tu utilises. Je mets
Bitnick entre guillemets. Est-ce qu'il y
a une une
bibliothèque
qui va pouvoir être accessible pour les
jeunes qui vont être obligés de nourrir
la France ? Est-ce que la perte de
savoir
ancestral
que le le patrimoine agric
d'agriculteur français va pas en fait
disparaître totalement et qu'on va
revenir avec 3 400 ans de de retard et
qu'on pourra pas utiliser toutes notre
notre patrimoine intellectuel autour de
l'agriculture. Est-ce qu'il y a une
est-ce qu'il y a une sauvegarde de
toutes ces connaissances ? Est-ce que
toi, mis à part dans tes bouquins, tu
notes ça précieusement ? Parce que vous
êtes pas tous les deux éternels. Vos
copains sont pas éternels, non plus. Nos
agriculteurs, les exploitations sont pas
éternelles. Il y a pas de il y a pas de
succession, il y a pas de reprise, donc
il y a pas de transmission de savoir.
Est-ce que tu connais
une base de données qui pourra servir
aux jeunes générations ? Non, pour le
moment je connais pas et je dirais même
que l'autre fois on est on a été à
l'agro parce qu'on voulait on voulait
l'agro c'est l'école de de l'école
supérieure d'cture de Paris qui
maintenant est à sa clé. Bon à l'époque
c'était encore à Paris euh pour avoir
les annales les annales agronomiques de
1940 à 1955.
On arrive,
la dame me donne une disquette molle,
souple.
Oh, je dis ils sont pas en avance au
niveau informatique. Et elle
[grognement] me dit vous allez vous
allez sur cet ordinateur. On cherche
avec Lydia, il y avait aucune entrée
pour le disquette mol on vi on revient
revoir la dame et on dit non mais il y a
l'ordinateur.
Ah oui, c'est vrai, on a changé les
ordinateurs. Alors je dit qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ?
Ah bah non, on a tout jeté à la
poubelle. On n pas on a plus. Il faut
que vous alliez à la bibliothèque
nationale de France.
C'est incroyable quand même. C'està-dire
que les gars, ils ont jeté à la
poubelle, ils ont gardé sur une
disquette molle 20 ans de
d'analonomique. C'est
donc ça veut dire il considère que le
travail des anciens c'est de la merde.
Il y a que la modernité qui est bonne
l'ancien.
Alors qu'ils nous disent tous les lieux
anciens.
En terme à l'échelle locale, euh tu leur
donnes quoi, Claude comme conseil à
[raclement de gorge] à notre communauté
? Tu leur dis planter des haricots,
plantez des tomates, planter ce que vous
pouvez, plantez ce qui pousse,
préparez-vous, faites des conserves. Tu
leur dis quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que tu leur dirais ?
un peu tout ce que tu je viens tu viens
de dire mais
c'est
tellement à l'échelle moi je pense
l'air de vous attrister tous les deux.
Oui, mais moi je pense que en fait on va
c'est c'est terrible ce que je vais dire
mais en fait on va laisser des des gens
pour compte si on continue comme ça. Ce
ce problème il est tellement grave
jusqu'aujourd'hui
mais il est tellement grave il faut
quand même la guerre va pas s'arrêter he
du jour au lendemain. On est bien
conscient
euh tous les conflits qu'on voit à
l'Ukraine ça ils sont dans leur 5e
année. Euh puis on parle pas du Soudan.
Enfin, les gens ne se ne voient pas tout
ce qui ce qui est. On n jamais autant eu
de pays. Là, on devait aller travailler
au Cambodge, on peut pas y aller parce
que c'est la guerre pour aider des
agriculteurs là-bas.
Donc ce cette aide pour des agriculteurs
en fait on pourra pas la faire ou on la
fera peut-être plus tard parce que en
fait ils sont en train entre la
Thaïlande pour des raisons X ou Y et je
pense que enfin effectivement moi je
suis il faut donner l'espoir c'est ce
qu'on essaie de de dire en en revenant
aux fondamentaux c'est-à-dire au niveau
et du du bah du sol mais que je on va
laisser des gens sur le bord de la route
je pense et même parce que c'est très
c'est très compliqué et pour nous les
gens nous disent vous êtes toujours un
peu bon dans la lune et tout mais la
base de du sol c'est la base de tout
c'est-à-dire que si on revient pas aux
fondamentaux de de qualité de et de et
aussi de de moins
de revenir à une nourriture qui est
aussi je dirais à l'échelle humaine et
pas du tout ce qu'on est en train de
nous faire manger, de récupérer. Nous,
on a travaillé en Afrique par exemple et
bien en fait les africains pour nous
nourrir pour avoir des haricots verts,
des fraises en hiver ne mangent pas à
leur fin. C'est pour nous servir nous
parce qu'on veut plus manger de rutabaga
ou de choses comme ça. En fait, il y a
il y a un vrai travail aussi de de du
citoyen de de manger peut-être moins de
meilleure qualité et de soutenir les
agriculteurs. et le monde, on est encore
on a encore un peu de moyens mais quand
on entend que la nourriture ne
représente représente moins que l'achat
de son téléphone de de toute la vidéo,
il y a un vrai problème. Autrefois
c'était presque la moitié de son
salaire. les gens pour se nourrir parce
que nourrir c'est façonner des enfants,
c'est façonner un cerveau quand vous
êtes mal nourri vous euh il y a il y a
un proverbe qui disait "Dis-moi ce que
tu manges, je te dirai ce que tu penss."
Et c'est une vraie réalité à l'heure
actuelle. Bon, on a on a une jeunesse
qui est complètement zombie parce que je
pense qu'elle est aussi déconnectée de
ce que c'est que de faire une vraie
tomate, de goûter une vraie tomate le
temps que ça met et que c'est pas de la
de l'acheter à peu de choses. Il y a un
vrai travail aussi au niveau du citoyen,
au niveau de de notre population de
de manger de façon, je dirais
raisonnable, respectueuse de du travail
de ces agriculteurs, de les reconnaître
et de pas dire bah la nourriture c'est
trop cher et et voilà.
Je peux je peux me faire avocat du
diable ? Bien sûr,
les étudiants qui font la queue pour des
colliers alimentaires, des étudiants qui
et des étudiantes qui sautent des repas
ou qui se prostituent pour pouvoir payer
leur loyer ou leur bouffe.
Quand tu quand tu les vois, euh les
gamins, ils peuvent pas se payer de la
bouffe bio, ils peuvent pas manger autre
chose que des pâtes qui sont sorties
d'une machine au téflon. Ils peuvent
pas, ils ont ils ont plus l'argent.
Claude, est-ce qu'on a pas dépassé le
point de nos retour ? C'est-à-dire
on est sur une société thermoindustriel
basé sur une consommation exponentielle
de calories fossiles. On a développé
notre population grâce aux intrans, à la
chimie, ainsi de suite. Et maintenant,
le politique se retrouve coincé.
Soit il continue la course à
l'échalotte, soit le peuple va lui faire
rouler sa tête et mettre sa tête au bout
d'une pique.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'ils en sont à
gérer ça entre la course à l'échalotte,
les fonds de retraite et leur tête au
bout d'une pique ?
Je sais pas, il reste technophile hein.
Il pense que la technique va résoudre
tous ces problèmes là. Il continue à y
croire alors que la technique gens je te
coupe parce qu'il faut que je la place.
Jacques Blamon disait la science et la
technologie ne vont pas nous sauver au
contraire de ce qu'on pense
et le mec est fondateur du programme
spatial français.
Vas-y. Désolé pour l'apparté.
Oui, c'était ce que disait Jacques Édul.
Le problème de la technique c'est qu'on
ne peut pas l'arrêter. C'est tout ce
qu'on peut faire on le fera. Même si
c'est nuisible, même si ça détruit. On
est en train de faire l'intelligence
artificielle et on va voir les
conséquences de ce truclà sur la
jeunesse, sur le le développement
intellectuel. Le QI s'effondre en
Occident.
On veut pas regarder la mortalité
infantile augmente en Occident, la gens
les jeunes deviennent stériles, 20 % des
enfants naissent par PMA. Donc il y a
vraiment un effondrement de l'état
sanitaire de la population parce que les
mal nourris avec des produits ultra
transformés
euh là ils viennent ça y est ils
viennent de comprendre que les que le
Coca-Cola américain fait avec du maïs
bah en fait ça provoque des cancers
graves. Donc ils sont en train de
découvrir plein de choses mais c'est
tellement complexe. On a tellement joué
avec tout ça, on a tellement transformé
les aliments pour pour essayer de faire
du pognon parce qu'en fait l'aliment
transformé est intéressant. Ils achètent
par exemple de l'huile de palme à bas
prix. Une année où c'est où le prix est
bas. Il manipulent tout ce tout ce
truclà pour fabriquer du gras dans des
dans des plats cuisiners dégueulasses.
Ils font du cracking, ils font pareil
que le sucre, ils font
et et le problème c'est que le corps
humain, il a jamais consommé ces trucs
là. Il est pas fait pour consommer ces
trucs-là. Et donc on a un
[raclement de gorge] état sanitaire
général de la population et intellectuel
qui va très mal. Donc comment on va
réagir ? Je vois pas les hommes
politiques. Est-ce que Macron a une
connaissance minimale de ce qu'est
l'agriculture ? Je pense pas.
Je pense pas. Enfin, je je vois les au
miss de l'agriculture.
C'est que c'est dans les vieux pots
qu'on fait les meilleures confitures.
Oui, ça il doit le savoir. Oui, [rires]
mais mais
désolé Lydia, laisse, désolé.
Non, [grognement] mais au ministère de
l'agriculture, ils sont quand même d'une
incompétence absolument effrayante parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas regarder ce que la
vie d'un sol. Ils veulent pas comprendre
la complexité de ce milieu pour eux. Tu
tu les trouves un peu en panique en ce
moment au ministère de l'agriculture ou
il faut voir qui on a comme ministre de
l'agriculture quand même.
Comment il s'appelle déjà le nouveau là
? Parce que ça change tellement.
Ouais mais celle qui a qui a enfin bon
moi j'ai oublié son nom et ben ils l'ont
changé parce que
comment elle a géré la crise du mois de
décembre ?
Annie Jeunev.
Merci. Comment Annie Junev ? Comment
elle a géré la crise du mois de décembre
? C'est c'est lamentable. C'est
lamentable les propos qu'elle avait au
niveau des agriculteurs. On voyait très
bien que cette femme ne connaissait rien
à l'agriculture. Je dis bien et
d'ailleurs, elle était pas d'un elle
était pas issue de d'un milieu agricole.
Elle n'avait pas fait d'études. Elle
Lydia, tu débarques. Regarde, regarde
comment il s'appelle l'autre là.
Oui, je débarque.
Bruno Lemire,
un hectare
quand il était ministre de
l'agriculture, il savait même pas ce que
c'était un hectar. Bon, maintenant, il a
été il a été ministre de de de
l'économie, il sait il sait pas faire
une TVA. Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
Bon, désolé pour la blague. Vas-y,
continue.
Oui, mais bon et comment comment aussi
quand tu as en face quelqu'un et dans
nos politiques de gens qui ne
connaissent pas le problème et qui
viennent aider soi-disant ou les
soutenir, ça peut pas marcher.
Ça peut pas marcher.
Normalement,
laisse ta femme terminer parce que
m'intéresse là. Vas-y. [rires]
C'est c'est en fait personne ne
s'entend. Les agriculteurs ne sont pas
compris et elle comme elle ne comprend
rien comme elle ne comprenait rien ou
des autres et bien c'est pareil. Donc en
fait on fait croire, on agite le je
dirais le drapeau blanc, on leur fait
croire ce qu'on veut, vous allez avoir
des primes, vous allez voir ceci et
tout. Et en fait pour calmer et
d'ailleurs la façon dont on a calmé le
le cette manifestation hein, c'est on a
agité euh le citoyen qui allait pas
pouvoir passer Noël et tout, mais ces
gens-là qui crèvent qui pleurent sur
leur bétail qu'on a tué sans que
personne n'écoute les problèmes de de
scientifiques qui disaient que on tuait
on éliminait une des bêtes mais qui
avait pas besoin de tout éliminer. La
France, c'est quand même incroyable. On
les a, je sais pas, on les a considéré
comme moins rien. Comment comment on
peut être dans un même bah
il peut pas y avoir de de enfin oui, il
peut pas y avoir de paix. Les
agriculteurs sont vent debout et chaque
fois et il faut voir aussi comment oui
après il manifeste plus parce que il y a
d'abord ils sont pas reconnus et puis
dans certains cas ben ça va trop loin.
On les gaze ou un truc comme ça.
On les blindé.
Voilà. Et et ça ça peut pas aller tant
qu'on a'ura pas aussi des politiques qui
connaissent parfaitement, je dirais ou
euh oui parfaitement ou au moins un
minimum euh le problème des
agriculteurs, des problèmes de la chute
des rendements, de la perte de ben de en
ce moment du fiou du est-ce que tu
entends est-ce qu'on entend à ce
moment-là des politiques en train de
dire attention, il va pas y avoir de il
va pas y avoir de d'engrais, il va y
avoir une pénurie. Est-ce que tu entends
des des politiques qui euh qui essaient
de bah de de préparer ou de rien du tout
?
Une question, tu me poses une question
là ?
Non, je me la pose à moi-même. [rires]
Est-ce que
Parce que nous on les entend pas, hein.
Bah, on les entend pas. On les voit, on
les voit promettre
mais ils connaissent pas les
fondamentaux
et ils sont Oui. Oui. Mais c'est pour ça
que en fait c'est des chaises médicales
les politiques ils sont un jour
ministres de l'agriculture le lendemain
euh c'est comme enfin c'est comme moi si
du jour au lendemain je décide de faire
autre chose que ce que je fais depuis
toujours.
Dans ses étoiles
[rires]
à mon âge. Oui. Mais et et ça ne peut
pas ce qui fait que
la jeunesse, on parle des jeunes et en
fait on ne donne je trouve en plus s'il
y avait un peu plus d'énergie, quelque
chose de qui va un peu un peu mieux mais
je veux dire la la jeunesse ne va plus
voter. La jeunesse n'est plus intéressée
par ça parce que en fait en face
qu'est-ce qu'elle a ? Elle a des
marionnettes. Elle a des gens aussi qui
sont corrompus. Quelles sont les valeurs
qu'on donne
et qu'on laisse
Claude,
les hommes politiques ont confié le
développement de l'agriculture en Europe
à la grande industrie. C'est ils se sont
totalement débarrassés du problème de
l'agriculture. Ils ont dit à la grande
industrie, vous vous occupez du
développement agricole. Or
l'agroindustrie, qu'est-ce qu'elle a
fait ? Elle a fait comme toutes les
industries, elle s'est occupé de ses
bénéfices. Elle en a rien à fiche les
agriculteurs, c'est pas son problème.
Elle essaie de voir qu'est-ce qui lui
rapporte. Là, elle est ravie qu' a le
mercosour parce que l'actalis va pouvoir
avoir du lait pas cher, la vi autre
ou autre chose. Toutes les grosses
boîtes agroindustriel sont ravis qu'il a
le mercoso. Elles vont avoir la matière
première pas cher. Fait l'avocat du
diable. Bah les prix les prix vont être
moins chers pour le consommateur
européen.
Oui, il sera mo
Qu'est-ce que tu fais chier Claude ?
Oui. Oui.
Ça va être moins cher. Oui, donc on
on va peut-être perdre notre
agriculture. Mais
Oui, mais quelle qualité de
d'alimentation aussi. Tu as vu aussi la
les normes, c'est-à-dire que il était
question qu'on mette un on mette des
gardes fous et que on on interdirait, on
ne ferait pas rentrer donc des des
animaux puisque le mercur c'était
surtout pour le bétail hein plus que au
départ et et que il y aurait des normes
et en fait la la politique a fait que
comme c'était un le mercour quelque
chose de de d'Européens et bien en fait
c'est c'est tombé à l'eau puisque on ne
pouvait pas donner des interdictions, je
schématise de ces produits-là parce
qu'en fait c'était les empêcher à vendre
en France. Donc ça veut dire que cette
c'est cette nourriture
en Argentine, enfin dans les pays de de
d'Amérique du Sud, on a travaillé, je
veux dire, il y a pas de restriction sur
le glyphosate, il y a pas de restriction
sur certains produits, sur certains
antibiotiques et tout et donc on va
avoir cette nourriture là qui sera moins
chère effectivement mais dans le futur
qu'est-ce que ça donnera ? Et en fait on
a sur la sécurité sociale
ou enfin bon on va parler de on peut en
parler après et en fait notre min notre
président de la République a dit que il
allait maintenir et tout et en fait il
l'a pas maintenu et le mercossour a été
signé avec aucune clause de protection
et d'égalité et d'égalité de produit
entre un un bœuf français de et un bœuf
c'est pas du tout la même chose. On
parle pas du même produit. On parle d'un
torchon et d'une serviette.
C'est que l'agriculture c'est le facteur
de d'ajustement de de l'économie. Il y a
un exemple très typique, c'est la
l'effondrement de la des moutons, de
tout ce qui est mouton en France qui est
dû à l'histoire du du Rainbow Varior où
les français, le service secret français
s'est planté, ils ont tué un photographe
et tout. Qu'est-ce qu'a fait Mitran pour
étouffer le scandale politique avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande ? Il a dit "Vous faites
rentrer vos moutons gratos." C'est un
pays où il y a 70 millions de moutons.
Le qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en France
les gars ? L'effondrement du prix du
mouton. Donc pour tenir le coup,
qu'est-ce que font les bergers ?
[grognement] Ils essayent d'avoir 2000 à
3000 moutons pour essayer de survivre
quoi. Le problème c'est qu'on rentre pas
2000 moutons tous les soirs dans une
bergerie. Surtout qu'on a laissé
s'effondrer les bergeries puisil y avait
plus de loup en France. Donc les gars se
retrouvent à essayer de surveiller 2000
moutons, ce qu'ils peuvent pas faire la
nuit et on accuse le loup d'être
responsable de la du alors que c'est pas
ça, c'est parce que on lit tous les
textes anciens sur la gestion, un homme
ne peut pas gérer correctement plus de
200 moutons parce qu'après c'est des
problèmes pour les rentrer dans les
bergeries, c'est des Donc si on peut pas
rentrer protéger les bêtes la nuit, tu
vois, c'est comme si les renards avaient
disparu en France que tout le monde
laisse les poules la nuit se balader, le
renard revient et on dit "Oh, c'est la
seule prix de renard qui tue mes
poules". Oui, mais on sait que les
renards tuent les poules depuis
toujours. On rentre les poules dans le
poulailler. Enfin, je sais pas c'est et
ce réflexe là était perdu. Et donc
maintenant bah on est en train de perdre
toute la filière mouton en France à
cause de la politique. C'est pas c'est
enfin Mitran n'avait pas à faire ça. Il
il pouvait faire autre chose mais pas
pas saccager la l'élevage de mouton
français.
On aura la même chose. On aura la même
chose avec le mercour
parce que ça va être une viande qui va
pas qui est pas cher en plus. le niveau
de vie, on est il y a aucune égalité. Le
niveau de vie n'est pas le même.
C'est-à-dire que les agriculteurs, enfin
ceux qui travaillent n'ont pas bon déjà
il gagnent pas beaucoup. En France,
c'est déjà très bas dans ces pays-là,
c'est encore plus bas. Donc de toute
façon, on sera pas compétitif. Il y a le
mot comp, on sera pas compétitif. Et les
agriculteurs, c'est aussi ça qui
demandaient. Il demandait une
protection. On s'est trouvé euh en plein
en plein euh [grognement]
ben conflit. On faisait une conférence à
Montmarsan avec les autoroutes bouchées
partout les euh par les agriculteurs et
tout et on a fait une conférence avec
des agriculteurs qui pleuraient, des
éleveurs qui pleuraient et qui disaient
que en fait euh bah toute la génétique,
il y avait une jeune femme là qui
parlait de de d'une sélection
de ses vaches depuis avec de son père de
son grand-père, de son père de et en
fait elle le ciel que en fait elle est
pas la maladie parce qu'on allait lui
tuer tout son troupeau. Un troupeau
sélectionné depuis
trois générations
et on a fait ça. On a on en a eu
d'autres en savoir on a fait ça parce
que quelqu'un a décidé c'est incroyable.
Donc on balaye aussi une sélection de de
bêtes qui étaient euh comme dit euh et
euh et je il y avait euh euh là c'est il
y avait quelqu'un qui comprenait pas
pourquoi euh pourquoi en fait elle était
autant attachée à ses bêtes. Mais en
fait les les agriculteurs
dans le monde animal, enfin les
éleveurs, mais même
un un maréché en fait bah l'éleveur il
va en fait il aime ses bêtes, il les
appelle ses filles et tout et donc il y
en avait un qui disait bon un
journaliste qui disait "Mais je
comprends pas vous les aimez vos bêtes"
mais ça veut dire parce que il y avait
oui on on met moi je parle aussi
d'énergie et on oublie complètement ça
la nourriture quand elle était porté par
des hommes et des femmes, vous donnez
aussi une énergie et on vit aussi de ça
et ça on occulte complètement ça. Mais
peut-être que l'agriculteur, il voit
aussi le travail de son père dans le
regard de sa vache tous les jours.
Peut-être pour ça qu'il les aime.
Bon après des questions débiles de
journalistes, moi je vais te dire il y a
plus de journalistes en France, c'est
terminé.
C'est terminé. Là on leur déclare la
guerre. C'est terminé.
Claude, je vais te poser une question
qui est en dehors de ton spectre, mais
on va parler d'homme à homme. Tu as pas
l'impression qu'on est en train de Tu
m'autorises à parler vulgairement devant
ta femme, Lydia ? Tu m'autorises bien
sûr.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'on est en
train de couper les rousons de la France
? Notre principal pilier de
souveraineté, c'est-à-dire la bouffe
bien franco-française
pour qu'ensuite la France ne fasse plus
chier en Europe et suivre toutes les
directives européennes. Tu as pas
l'impression que c'est une mise au pas
pure et simple de la France alors
par une technure
apatride qui sous des faux prétextes de
on va donner à manger à tout le monde,
on va se faire des bisous et tout ira
bien, ce sera la paix l'Europe. Tu as
pas l'impression qu'en fait il y a une
technructure qui est en train de dire
bon la France ils ont quand même le
nucléaire et s'ils ont leur deuxième
jambe avec l'agriculture ils vont
pouvoir dire aux Allemands maintenant tu
vas te calmer Fritz
maintenant la France va reprendre son
rang et vous arrêtez mais quand tu as
plus d'énergie que tu as plus
d'agriculture tu es condamné non à faire
rien
ah ça un pays qui a plus son agriculture
qui nourrit plus sa population il est
cuire c'est un pays qui est foutu et
[grognement] c'est pas pour rien si on
classé la gastronomie française
patrimoine c'est au moment où ça
s'effondre toujours comme ça c'est au
moment où les choses s'écroulent hop on
les protège on protège la nature une
fois qu'il y en a plus on dit on va
protéger littoral une fois qu'ils sont
bien pollués puis bien détruit et
[grognement] c'est vrai que la
gastronomie française elle est cuite
parce qu'elle a pluie les produits de
base qui lui permettent de faire une
bonne alimentation et ça c'est comment
on répare un truc pareil quand on a
enfin il y a quand même des trucs
délirants. On ne peut pas faire une
pomme à hausser limousin avec autre
chose que la Golden si on qui est une
une variété américaine dont on paye les
brevets. Si on utilise des des pommes
locales du limousin, on n pas le droit à
la hausser. Donc tout est tout est
fabriqué pour détruire le système
d'Aussé, détruire la la l'originalité du
produit qui était la racine des choses.
Et une fois que c'est détruit
effectivement la France sera comme il se
défend pas trop mal en Europe, c'est
l'Italie hein. L'Italie avec le avec ce
qu'ils appellent le slow food, il
protège des variétés de lentilles, des
variétés de haricot, des variétés de
poire et cetera. C'est encore une petite
agriculture, 10 hactares de moyenne
contre 80 hactares en France et et les
Italiens sont se restent attachés. Alors
pendant longtemps, ils ont lutté contre
les supermarchés. Bon maintenant
l'Europe les a forcé à les accepter mais
l'Italie l'italien lui c'est une
nourriture
familiale mais de très belle qualité. He
c'était Kurnonski le prin le prince des
gastronomes disait "La France est unique
au monde. Bah c'est le pays qui a quatre
gastronomies. la gastronomie familiale,
les blanquettes de veau, les
voilà pour quelque chose qu'on faisait à
la maison comme ça, la gastronomie
locale hein, les l'enduillette de Vir,
le jambon
de Dijon et cetera la gastronomie de
fête quand on invite des amis et cetera.
Alors là, on met les grands petits plats
dans les grands plats. Voilà. et la
gastronomie de luxe. Il dit c'est le
seul pays au monde qui a ça. Et et c'est
quelque chose d'assez étonnant ce qui
montre que les français étaient attachés
là. Donc maintenant on est le deuxè pays
en nombre de McDo par habitant après les
États-Unis. Ah c'est quandme ça monte
quand même la chute la chute de cette
notion. Il y a combien de jeunes qui
savent encore cuisiner hein ? Les quel
pourcentage de jeunes qui cuisinent
encore en France. On a on a réussi à
casser quand même un système qui était
remarquable qui était vraiment
remarquable et ça on du mal à remettre
ça debout. Je crois qu'il reste plus
qu'un seul producteur de cornichon en
France. Il reste deux producteurs de
Ouais. La moutarde, elle vient de elle
vient du Canada. Le crisson, je crois
qu'il y a plus que deux crissonnières en
France. C'est c'est affolant quoi. C'est
comment on a détruit un patrimoine
absolument. Il y a des moutardes dans le
vexin. D'ailleurs, je recommande
[raclement de gorge] d'ailleurs.
[grognement]
Oui oui, on essaie de quand même de
refaire de la moutarde mais c'est vrai
que face à la moutarde canadienne qui
est beaucoup moins chère, on a du mal à
résister quoi.
Vous deux, vous voyez les choses comment
pour les nouvelles générations ? Alors,
on va écluser la guerre, on va prier
pour que nos politiciens nous
décongèlent des tablettes de beurre
quand on aura faim. C'est une boutade,
on expliquera plus tard. Vous voyez
comment les choses pour les jeunes
générations ?
Pas très
ben pas très heureuse pour eux. C'est la
première fois que les parents pensent
que leurs enfants vont vivre moins bien
queeux, vont avoir moins de possibilité
que nous, que moi mais je sais que mes
enfants et mes petits-enfants euh auront
auront une vie beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus difficile. N'uront même pas les ben
le le travail, la nourriture qu'on a eu.
Donc je suis pas très très optimiste
pour pour eux vu que bah il y a pas
grand-chose qui qui bouge chaque fois.
Chaque fois quand même on est aussi dans
un pays où dès que quelqu'un a la parole
soit il va être mis de côté avec une une
rumeur, une fake news qui va
complètement le mettre de côté. Soit
dans certains cas, dans certains pays
euh les le Brésil, c'est le pays où on
tue le plus d'écologistes ou de gens de
qui respectent leur sol. Donc euh c'est
on en parle pas de de de ces gens qui
veulent ça.
Euh
moi je je je il y a il y a pas de je
oui, je suis pas je suis pas du tout euh
je suis pas je suis pas optimiste pour
eux et d'autant plus que en fait ils ont
pas euh ils ont pas on le on le en fait
dans l'éducation
c'est une éducation qui est biaisée. On
leur donne pas les vraies valeurs, ils
sont tous sur la technique sans sans I
maintenant à l'heure actuelle où on
parlait de l'IA, ben je vois on a des
enfants et des petits enfants et bien en
fait quand ils ont un problème ils vont
à ils vont pas ouvrir un livre, ils vont
pas faire la démarche de faire quelque
chose tout de suite on leur ils sont
gavés, perfusés de mais sans que il y
ait la moindre pensée.
Ils appellent pas mamie. Comment ça se
fait qu'ils appellent pas mamellent pas
mamie ? Non, pas du tout. Et on avait
notre petite fille qui faisait
euh qui a changé puisqueelle veut faire
psycho, ben effectivement, elle veut
être psychologue. Elle là, c'est un
métier d'avenir, ça c'est sûr, ça il y a
pas de problème. Mais il y a un moment,
elle voulait, elle se dirigeait vers de
l'environnement. Elle n'est jamais venue
nous demander le moindre renseignement.
Elle disait "Mais chat GPT, ça va très
bien, ça va plus vite que vous."
Donc ça monte et pourtant elle a des
parents, elle a des grands-parents qui
sont [grognement] donc moi je je et je
on critique beaucoup aussi
bah ce qu'on leur enseigne
CL
l'enseignement
ce qu'on appelait l'éducation parce que
on disait pas on disait l'enseignement
public hein maintenant ça c'est devenu
l'éducation nationale. C'est pas l'état
d'éduquer les enfants, c'est par l'État
doit enseigner mais il doit pas éduquer
hein. et on nenseigne plus. Qu'est-ce
qu'on enseignait autrefois ? À raconter,
à lire, à à
écrire
à écrire et puis on avait des cours de
cuisine, on avait des cours de on nous
apprenait ce qu'était les plantes. Moi
je me souviens de la carte de France,
toutes les zones agricoles qui étaient
décrites. Là, on fait du vin, là on fait
de la betterave, là on fait de la
viande, là on fait tout ça c'est plus
enseigné. Le on a il y avait des cours
de pour apprendre à tricoter, pour
apprendre la musique, pour apprendre
tout ça, c'est fini. Donc on a une
génération qui ne sait même pas planter
des radis ni des salades. Il ne savent
rien. Rien. Et c'est d'ailleurs des
instituteurs qui nous le disent. Moi,
j'ai jamais appris à reconnaître les
champs des oiseaux, à reconnaître les
plantes. Je sais pas quel arbre. Je sais
pas, je peux pas dire à des gamins quand
je les emmène dans forêt, ça c'est ça
c'est de l'érable champêtre, ça c'est du
être. Ça ils savent plus, c'est plus
enseigné.
C'est traité de naturaliste hein. Quand
on fait ça, on est un naturaliste alors
ça avec le filet à papillon.
Oui, filet à papillon. Que s'il y a un
gamin qui su ou il va pas savoir
reconnaître qu'il faut emmener le gamin
à l'ostau.
Mais c'est vrai, on en est là. Ouais. Je
me souviens, on nous avait demandé dans
les journées de la science de de c'était
à l'époque où on avait encore la
possibilité de rentrer dans dans une
école, dans un collège ou dans un lycée
et là c'était des 6e et des 5e. Et donc
la personne nous dit euh on fait venir
euh chaque fois tous les mois quelqu'un
qui a un métier un peu extraordinaire.
Donc ça peut être la dernière fois
c'était une femme qui était qui était
pianiste. Ils ont fait venir quelqu'un
qui faisait du sport de haute
compétition et là ils ont eu ils nous
ont demandé si on pouvait intervenir.
Mais il nous a dit c'est des 6e non 6e,
5e et 4e c'est des c'est des enfants. Il
va falloir faire quelque chose qui soit
dynamique, qui les captif, qui avec à
base de photos, que ça soit pas trop
scientifique. Enfin, il nous il nous
brief. en disant faites attention bon on
prépare quelque chose
cl arrive avec sa pelle
non non là on était on était en salle on
prépare je dis à Claude je on va faire
un avec des photos qui les inspirent et
tout il y avait pas il avait 10 minutes
un quart d'heure enfin peut-être 20
minut un quart d'heure ça commençait à
bouger on voyait que bon ça les
intéressait pas pas trop donc
on on a dit
Et ben qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
dans la vie ? Est-ce que notre métier
parce qu'on leur a dit et tout, est-ce
que quelqu'un voudrait faire le métier
que que nous faisons ?
Donc la réponse c'était quoi ? C'était
homme politique ou instagrameuse ?
[rires]
Non, c'était Et ils ont personne n'a dit
"Ah ben non, on veut pas faire des
métiers de d'agriculteur, on veut pas
s'occuper de ça et tout. Qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire dans la vie ?" Alors,
il y avait footballeur, danseuses,
chanteuses,
influenceuses,
influenceuse. Et on pose la question
"Mais attendez là bon, il y avait une
quarantaine de personnes de gamins, on
leur dit "Mais comment vous allez manger
?" Parce que quand même, si tout le
monde est footballeur, si tout le monde
est danseur, comment vous allez manger ?
Et il y en a un qui dit "Ah ben c'est
pas difficile, on va aller au
supermarché."
On dit oui mais ce qu'il y a dans le
supermarché tu sais c'est quand même des
agriculteurs qui font et et tout. Et euh
il y a un moment
on lui dit "Ton pain, les pâtes c'est
fait avec de la farine, le riz c'est un
agriculteur et tout." Et là la réponse
de ce gamin qui devait être en bon
peut-être en en 5e, il dit "Mais même le
Rion Clubens, il est cultivé
Donc ça va être compliqué hein.
Donc pour lui c'était une boîte avec du
riz mais qui ne qui sortait pas de la
terre.
C'est quand même incroyable.
Alors
cet enfant n'avait même pas pour lui euh
Claude a sorti sa pelle.
Ouais. Non, mais c'est pour c'est pour
dire à quel point en fait les même ben
ce que disait Claude, ils savent pas
mais un gamin, il a aucune idée même de
comment se cultive. Bah oui, une tomate.
Est-ce que une tomate c'est est-ce que
elle est sur un arbre ? Ils savent même
pas. Une fraise, ça pourrait être
l'arbre fraisier et tout. Il y a des
réflexions comme ça. Donc, ils sont
complètement décollectés de de la nature
et du sol. On avait donné, on avait fait
une confiance sur les sols au lycée de
Valence qui produisent des fruits, des
pêches, des abricots. On y était en
pleine saison des abricots et des
pêches. On va à la cantine avec les
professeurs et au dessert, il y avait
des danettes en fait des cochonneries
industrielles et et on leur dit d'autres
noms d'autres noms.
Oui. Euh donc on leur dit mais pourquoi
une crème une crème toute faite ? une
crème toute faite, on leur dit "Mais
pourquoi vous ne vous leur donnez pas
vous avez des fruits extraordinaires que
les gamins et les gamins taillent les
arbres pourquoi vous leur donnez pas les
fruits ?" Et réponse "On n'a pas le
droit, c'est interdit parce qu'il
pourrait y avoir une intoxication."
Donc je dis vous expliquez donc aux
gamins que ce qu'ils ont fait pendant
toute l'année à tailler les arbres et
cetera, c'est pas comestible. Mais
comment voulez-vous qu'ils deviennent
des agriculteurs ? Ils peuvent pas.
Ils peuvent pas. C'est impossible avec
des lois comme ça.
On était dans on était dans un autre,
c'était près du Massif Central et là
c'était pour des jeunes qui étaient pour
devenir éleveurs et c'était surtout
éleveur de de race porcine. Donc il y
avait pas mal de porc et là on là on a
fait un profil, on a et à midi on va
manger à la cantine et il y avait je me
souviens bon des pâtes avec euh bah du
jambon
non non les pâtes avec du jambon et donc
les gamins on prenaient nous on en a on
en a eu puisque c'était franchement
c'était pas mangeable. Les gamins ont
jeté toute cette nourriture.
Appelé nourriture.
Ouais. Appelé nourriture. Et nous on dit
"Ah bah c'est formidable. Enfin bon,
c'est formidable. C'est dommage mais en
fait vous allez donner ça à vos cochons.
Et là le le directeur dit "Ah non, ça
c'est pas possible, ça va être incinéré.
On peut pas donner ça au cochons, on les
nourrit au soja."
Et là, je me souviens lui avoir dit
"Mais vous rendez compte le symbolisme
que vous vous faites passer ?"
C'est-à-dire que cette nourriture que
vous donnez aux gamins qui peuvent pas
manger tellement c'est mauvais, vous la
brûlez parce que c'est pas bien pour les
cochon et vous faites venir du soja au
GM des États-Unis. Il dit il et là il
répondit "J'avais pas pensé à ça."
Ah mais mais c'est c'est les mêmes
choses. C'est-à-dire que ces gamins qui
dans ces collèges, on a fait celui-là,
on en a fait un autre, c'était pour pour
des fromages. En fait, ils ne peuvent
pas là, ils mangaient pas le cochon.
Peut-être que c'était le jambon issu de
leur cochon, mais en fait ils ne peuvent
pas. Il ils sont dans un lycée agricole.
On leur apprend quelque chose sur l' sur
l'agriculture, sur la nourriture,
comment on fait ? Et quand et ben ils
ont pas le droit de manger ce qu'ils ont
produit parce que il y a un risque
d'intoxication. Mais c'est absolument
grave.
C'est comme si dans une école de des
bénisteries, on leur apprend à faire une
table et après on la détruit, on la
jette, on la brûle.
C'est pareil.
C'est pareil. C'est ça qu'on met dans la
tête des jeunes dans les lycées
agricoles. C'est c'était ça. On peut pas
avoir des des agricurs qui fassent autre
chose que de se suicider avec des un
enseignement pareil.
Si on leur donnait un enseignement où
quelque part en leur faisant prendre
conscience que en fait le métier
d'agriculture c'est un très beau métier
parce que c'est un métier effectivement
de d'abord on donne à manger et puis il
est d'une universalité puisque bah il
faut connaître bon les céréales. On
apprend énormément. Alors qu'on fait
croire que c'est le dernier des métiers
qu'on peut faire. [raclement de gorge]
Donc on on ne donne pas envie à la
jeunesse. Il ils préféront être à la
chaîne ou faire un boulot vraiment pas
qui valorise pas, qui fait pas penser et
tout. un agriculteur, il est obligé
enfin on on l' enlevé le bon sens et la
pensée aux agriculteurs. Mais si on
remettait ce métier aussi dans
l'idée de de valeur, je pense qu'on
aurait beaucoup plus de jeunes qui
reprendraient les fermes et qui en fait
resteraient auprès à la nature. Mais
c'est pas le cas. C'est pas le cas. Là,
on voit des agriculteurs qui veulent pas
semer parce que ça ça va leur coûter
trop cher
et qu'en plus ils vont pas pouvoir
répercuter les prix sur les
consommateurs parce que il voit bien que
les consommateurs
bah ils ont plus beaucoup d'argent non
plus. Donc quand tu as une dorée
périssable que tu sors très cher et bah
derrière si le consommateur achète pas
bah
ça part et ça part à la la poubelle.
Euh là, on voit des des agriculteurs
préférés faire du gaz par métanisation
plutôt que de faire de la bouffe. On
voit des agriculteurs préférés mettre
leur paille à la méthanisation
plutôt que que les éleveurs et de la
paille.
Et on va où avec tout ça là ?
Oui, c'est écrave.
Oui oui parce que c'est on perd il y a
un nombre de surfaces agricoles qui
permettent de de se nourrir qui sont en
train de partir pour faire de l'énergie.
Le colza tout ça ? Bah oui, mais le le
muscus, il y a même en fait toutes même
les pailles, les pailles, elles sont
utilisées puisque pour faire de la
méthanisation et ces pailles,
normalement elles étaient achetées par
des éleveurs et les le les le ces boîtes
qui font euh la méthanisation en fait
sont prêts à payer plus cher pour pour
être sûr d'avoir de la paille. Parce que
le problème du méthaniseur, comme tout
est fait en aérobiose hein, il faut
en aérobiose, il faut qu'il y ait pas
d'oxygène dès s'il y a le moindre pépin
dans un méthaniseur, ils sont obligés de
tout vider, tout rincer, ça coûte
énormément cher. Donc il faut sans
arrêt, c'est comme un ogre, il faut sans
arrêt sans arrêt lui donner de la ben de
bah de du végétal et même des déchets
pour pour pouvoir se se faire ce métal.
Mais c'est quand même incroyable ça. On
consomme de l'énergie pour pour cultiver
euh bah si on a un tracteur, il va
utiliser du fiou pour pouvoir semer euh
ou labourer quand il labour et et euh et
en fait on fait un méthaniseur pour
redonner de l'énergie et cette ces
surfaces ne vont pas aller euh pour
l'alimentation. Il y a des des gens.
Alors, il y a quand même de plus en plus
une norme où en fait on demande à ce que
ça soit pas euh le blé parce que il y a
un moment il ils achetaient même du blé
plus cher que le blé pour faire du pain
pour pour de la méthanisation. Et alors
en plus comme c'est de la naérobiose,
les déchets de ces usines quand ils ont
Nous on a fait du travail, on a mesuré
l'activité biologique, ça tue tout parce
que les germes anaérobiques, c'est les
clostridium du tétanos, c'est les
salmonnelles, c'est que des germes
toxiques. Donc quand vous épendez ça sur
le sol, ça tue les verrs de terre, ça
tue la faune du sol. Alors les gens
disent ou c'est pas grave, ils se
régénéreront. Non,
enfin bon, je veux dire alors déjà nos
sols, il manque de matière organique.
Maintenant, cette matière organique, on
la transforme en méthane pour faire de
l'énergie parce qu'on est obsédé par
l'énergie et puis le reste c'est mortel.
Enfin, je veux dire c'est quand même des
modèles qui sont hyper mortifères
et qui sont encouragés par des
subventions européennes. C'est ça. En
plus, c'est entièrement parce que ça
gagne rien, c'est entièrement
subventionné. Non, mais on délire
délire.
Et puis et puis il y a des il y a des de
il y a des dangers. Puisque en fait
Claude il parlait de de des digests. Les
digestats comme on leur air on retiré
tous leur carbone pour faire du méthane
et bien en fait ils sont riches qu'en
azote. Ils sont très très riches en
azote. On met ça sur les sols. Claude a
dit ça peut ça tue la faune et tout mais
en fait au niveau des nafréatiques ça va
être absolument catastrophique parce
qu'on est déjà trop riche en en nitrate
et ce nitrate comme il y en aura trop et
bien en fait il va passer aussi on aura
une pollution des eaux
encore plus importante que ce qu'on a
déjà
pénurie d'œuf pénurie de poulet
Tranquille.
Oui, on est tranquille.
Laiss bl
ça se passe bien.
Oui, tout va bien.
Oui, tout va bien se passer. Va venir
maintenant les poulets, les œufs vont
venir du mercour donc d'Ukraine, ce sera
ce sera des œufs ukrainiens.
Voilà.
Fini la petite boule noire avec ses œufs
bleus. Finis tout ça. Vous avez connu
[raclement de gorge] ça ce genre de
Ah oui, je c'est joli, hein, les œufs
bleus. C'est magnifique. Et puis c'est
bon.
Euh est-ce que vous avez écrit un un
bouquin là ? Non. Comment il s'appelle
ce nouveau bouquin ? C'est un bouquin.
On a écrit ça. C'est Pourquoi ne
faisons-nous rien pendant que la maison
brûle ?
Tu connais Jacques Chirac toi ?
Voilà. [raclement de gorge]
Se posait la question pourquoi après 30
copes
on a toujours pas pris la moindre
décision pour gérer cette cette planète
qui se qui a de plus en plus de mondes à
bord et qui qui elle ne grandit pas. Et
donc on essaie d'apporter, on a apporté,
on a trouvé 10 10 raisons pour
lesquelles on bouge pas.
Euh et la dernière, mais on l'a mis tout
à fait à la fin du livre parce que ça on
savait que si on le mettait au début,
les gens arrêteraient de le lire. C'est
une une raison toute simple, c'est que
les hommes sont fous. C'est c'est le la
médaille, le revers de la médaille de
notre cerveau très développé. Nous
sommes tous fous, hein. Pascal disait
"Nous sommes tellement fous que c'est
par un are jeu de de folie de croire que
nous ne sommes pas fous." Et avec on
s'intéressait à la folie dans la folie
humaine, qu'est-ce qui faisait qu'on
bougeait pas ? Et il y a les
psychologues ont divisé la folie humaine
en trois choses. Les psychoses, les
névroses et les perversités. Donc on a
cherché dans les psychoses qu'est-ce qui
faisait qu'on bougeait pas. Il y en a
une qui est que que le langage populaire
appelle la politique de l'autruche et le
déni.
C'est quand quelque chose devient trop
angoissant,
les hommes paniquent et je veux pas
voir, je veux pas entendre, je veux pas.
Et on est en plein dans le déni. C'est
intéressant de voir que plus les
incendiés augmentent, plus les
inondations augmentent, plus les
ouragans augmentent, plus il y a de de
climatosceptique. On est à plus de 50 %
maintenant en France. C'està-dire que
plus le système devient grave, plus les
gens veulent pas entendre politique de
l'Autriche. Ensuite, il y a l'Obrise.
Alors, l'oubriss je veux être le numéro
1 du luxe, le numéro 1 de la de
l'informatique, le numéro 1 de la SI et
cetera. Et c'est ce qu'on appelait la
euh alors dans le langage populaire, on
appelait ça la folie des grandeurs.
C'est illustré par l'oncle Pixou qui
sautait dans son dans sa baignoire
remplie de pièces d'or. Et ces gens-là
sont plus puissants maintenant que des
pays et donc ils imposent leur lois euh
et les pays sont obligés d'obéir. Il
sont des gafas américaines qui imposent
des lois à l'Europe et l'Europe est
obligée de de plier le genou. Et
[grognement] puis enfin il y a la
pas que le genou hein.
Ouais. Ouais. Pas que le genou. Puis
enfin il y a la perversité. Et dans les
perversités, il y a Paul Claude Racamier
qui a montré une chose intéressante,
c'est qu'il y a une perversité qui est
en train d'exploser dans la cité
occidentale. C'est le pervers
narcissique. Macron est un exemple
typique. Trump sont des exemples de
C'est
non mais Irigyen a montré après que ça
se transforma en harcèlement dans les
dans les dans les entreprises.
Le premier qui a montré ça c'était c'est
pas Claudamier. Et il combien temps que
vous êtes mariés tous les deux ?
presque 50 ans. Tu dis ça d'un ton.
[rires]
Vas-y, continue. Ou ou en janvier de
l'année prochaine, ça fera 50 ans. Vous
faites une petite fête quand même, non ?
Ah oui. On fera une petite fête. Ah oui,
une grosse fête.
Ah ouais, je v
Ah bah écoute, je peux ramener quelques
caisses de chez moi. [rires]
On comparera.
Ça ne se compare pas.
Non, ça se compare pas.
Ça se goûte.
Ça se goûte. Exactement.
Et et en fait, on se rend compte que
dans un monde qui est dominé par
l'argent, il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
familles qui sont déséquilibrées.
C'est-à-dire que les deux sont obsédés
par leur boulot et s'occupent plus de
leur gosse. Or, l'enfant, c'est un puit
d'amour. Il a besoin d'être aimé
tendrement et tout pour pouvoir se
structurer psychiquement. Et quand on
l'est pas, c'est le cas de Macron qui a
été élevé par sa grand-mère puisque sa
mère et son père s'occupait pas de lui.
Bah,
il a peut-être reçu beaucoup d'amour de
sa grand-mère, hein.
Peut-être. Oui, mais c'est pas le même
amour quand même. Et ça crée un vide
intérieur et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ours mal léché dans le langage
populaire. Et ces gens là ont beaucoup
de mal à ressentir l'empathie. Ils ont
beaucoup de mal à prendre conscience de
la souffrance des autres et cetera. Donc
c'est des gens qui ont qui ne sont pas
capables [raclement de gorge] de faire
face au problème qui nous qui nous qui
est en train de nous tomber dessus là
qui est que ça va pas être les je pense
que les chaque année sera plus difficile
que l'année précédente. On est rentré
dans le craque écologique mais on veut
pas s'en on est dans le déniut pas
l'admettre.
Oui. Puis ça c'est un déni total pour
pour
pas que pour l'agriculture pour pour
quasiment la valeur du travail. Il y a
plus de on les employés, les salariés,
on les vide, ils sont il deviennent
chômeurs. Alors que les manias de ces
grosses boîtes font des des millions
de de salaires, il y a une corruption
incroyable. Comment demander à nos
jeunes enfin d'avoir de l'éthique ?
C'est pas possible. l'image que l'on
donne à au futur
où sont les valeurs ? On a perdu tout.
Enfin, [grognement] il y a
il y a pas de valeur. Les les les on
peut pas on peut pas se raccrocher à des
valeurs puisque il y a aucun enfin moi
je trouve autour de nous il y a il y a
rien qui qui permet de
Oui. de de pouvoir se regarder en face.
Tu
as déjà goûté la cuisine des pades ?
Tu as compris ?
Ouais.
Comment tu traites tes vieux ? Tu as
compris ?
Mais même euh j'ai fait un petit séjour
à l'hôpital il y a pas longtemps. Je
veux dire tous les malades faut voir ce
qu'on leur donne à manger. C'est
inadmissible. dans les écoles
maintenant, on fait un effort et on on
revient peut-être
mais comment
en étant mal nourri, comment on peut
avoir euh
du dynamisme,
une envie de de faire et puis même
d'être en bonne santé. Là, on a
un Cor, on a quelqu'un qui est venu
travailler qui qui est un rugby man et
tout. Il dit et prof de rugby et il dit
avant bon on se faisait des bleus. Il
dit moi maintenant les gamins ils se
cassent comme du vert. Dès qu'il se dès
qu'il tombe c'est une cheville qui qui
vo il dit ils sont plus costaud, ils
n'ont plus de solidité. Je connaissais
pas. Il dit j'ai peur quand quand il
court parce que en fait il se blesse
mais mais grave. Donc c'est pourquoi
pourquoi il y a autant de tout pourquoi
aussi il y a autant de problèmes de
santé ? C'est pas que lié
sédentarité, tout un tas de choses.
Oui, mais enfin bon, la sédentarité
quand c'est un gamin qui fait du rugby
ou du foot, c'est pas de la sédentarité
hein. C'est qu'en fait il est pas
quelque part, il est pas nourri
correctement.
Peut-être qu'il joue pas correctement.
Oui. Bon, d'accord.
Non.
Oui. Mais bon.
Tu faisais quoi quand tu étais jeune
Claude ? allait euh cueillir les
escargots de Bourgogne, contempler les
montres religieuses, observer les anons,
regarder les lézards. Ouais, c'est ça
que je faisais. Ouais, j'étais
naturaliste, j'adorais la nature et puis
avait j'ai fondé un club ornito avec des
copains en 4e, le groupe ornitologique,
le gop groupe ornitologique parisien qui
était le on savait pas que c'était le
great old party des États-Unis, sinon on
l'aurait pas appelé GOP. Et donc oui,
c'était ça. C'était aller voir les
oiseaux, aller voir la nature.
Qu'est-ce que tu racontes d'autre dans
ton bouquin ?
Alors, on raconte s'appelle le titre
déjà.
Pourquoi ne faisons-nous rien pendant
que la maison brûle ? Donc dans les dans
les choses qu'on dit,
bah déjà c'est enfin ça c'était la confé
ton mari 2 secondes s'il te plaît.
Pardon. [rires]
Alors ce qu'on ce qu'on disait c'est euh
bon, on parle de la technologie, la
passion pour la technologie, le problème
de l'agriculture industrielle, on parle
de la
Oui. d'une chose que je trouve
intéressante qui est que on ne lit plus
les anciens, on lit plus la poésie. Et
euh là haut ceux 5 siècles avant
Jésus-Christ disait une chose très
intéressante sur les civilisations. Il
disait au départ d'une civilisation, il
y a le charisme. Pour la nôtre, c'est le
Christ. Quand on perd l'eucharist dit là
au-dessus, on tombe dans la religiosité
hein, c'est les protestants contre les
catholiques, contre les orthodoxes.
Quand on perd la religiosité dit la
hauteur, on tombe dans la bonté hein,
c'est le on tricote pour les pauvres,
c'est le charity business, on est en
plein dedans. Quand on perd la la bonté
la hauteur, on tombe dans la justice et
en ce moment les avocats font fortune.
Tout le monde fait des procès à tout le
monde. Et quand on perd la justice, dit
la haute, on tombe dans le chaos. Et là,
la hausseur rajoute une chose très
intéressante. Quand on est dans le
chaos, les gens recherchent les racines
de la tradition. C'est que les corses
veulent être Corse, les bretons breton,
les les basques basques. Et on en plein
dans cette phase là. C'estàd chacun est
en train d'essayer de se dire "Merde, le
l'orage arrive, il faut que je me
protège." Et
c'est comme ça que tu analyses toute la
montée de du nationalisme en Europe, aux
États-Unis, un peu partout le monde.
C'est comme ça.
C'est comme ça que nous on l'interprète.
C'est peut-être peut-être pas mais c'est
une façon d'interpréter. Ouais. Il
a ta femme qui voulait dire un truc, tu
lui donnes la parole ou
non ? Non mais c'est c'est vrai que
c'est ces poètes ont dit ce qui est
incroyable c'est que on a mis énormément
de pensées de
bah de poètes de de philosophes et tout.
euh celle de la hauteux qui est qui est
importante.
Et euh en fait ce qui est incroyable
c'est que c'est ces poètes et je pense
qu'ils sont visionnaires parce queils
ont décrit pratiquement tout ce qui nous
arrive. En fait la Ésée Reclu disait que
en fait quand un agriculteur en fait il
faut qu'il il faut qu'il regarde son
sol, il faut qu'il connaisse son sol et
en fait il faut qu'il lui demande quelle
semence pour lui donner qu'il faut lui
donner et que c'est pas à à l'homme de
de
ben de commander et c'est ce qu'on fait.
On commande, je veux que ce sol me fasse
tant de quintau de blé. Je veux que il
me fasse tant de kilos de pommes. Et
c'était en 1700
1863 dans son tome 2.
Et c'est incroyable
ce que dit la Hauteu par rapport à ce
qu'on est en train de vivre. Et ces
gens-là sentaient tout. Et quand on les
lit et ben ils sont en train de nous
dire ce qui nous arrive. Oui, Élisé
Reclu explique que si on continue à
exploiter les poissons comme ça, on sera
envahi de méduse. C'est exactement ce
qui arrive.
Que si on coupe la forêt 19e
que si on coupe la forêt, on augmentera
les grê et on a tous les ans bah
lesvignons et d'autres, je veux dire
tous les ans on a des phénomènes de grê
et les anciens disent mais jamais ça
grêlait. On nétait pas dans un passage
mais parce qu'on a et il écrit plus on
déf restera, plus on aura de la grêle.
Alors moi, je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable.
Il y a jamais eu autant de forêt en
France.
Il a jamais eu autant
autant de forêt en France. Oui, mais
c'est des forêts de de sapin, c'est pas
des forêts de feuilles.
Donc
c'està dire qu'en fait on a on a séparé
les choses agricoles. C'est des endroits
où il y a que de la que de la forêt, des
endroits où il y a que de l'élevage, des
endroits où il y a que des céréales.
Alors qu'autrefois, il y avait un
maillage. Il y avait ce qu'on appelait
les hain, on avait des ha partout, les
animes qui se permettaient de de faire
circuler les bêtes d'une parcelle à
l'autre. Donc il y avait un véritable
équilibre agrosilvo pastoral tandis cas.
C'est où il y a que vous êtes dans les
landes, il y a que des que des arbres
qui brûlent parce que c'est des résineux
ou bien alors vous êtes que dans de la
céréale. Il y a plus un arbre, plus une
vous allez en bas, c'est le désert
biologique total, il y a plus
d'alouette, il y a plus rien et parce
que c'est la monoculture pure et c'est
pas ça la vie, elle est pas en
monoculture, elle est au contraire en
association,
et donc le le système là, il fonctionne
pas bien. Pas pas bien du tout.
Tu veux pas me parler un peu plus de ton
bouquin là ? Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on
Je te force à faire de la promo, c'est
dingue.
C'est incroyable.
Mais non, mais il est euh il faut pas en
faire la promo, il est il est épuisé
parce qu'on n' pas trouvé euh
on n pas trouvé on n' pas trouvé des
douteurs français qui voulaient en nous
disant euh vous êtes vous êtes
microbiologique des sols, vous vous
occupez du sol et vous avez pas à avoir
un penflet avec des idées qui n'ont rien
à voir avec le sol.
Donc on a trouvé une un petit éditeur
qui quasiment fait faillite. Donc le
livre est est passé au pilon et donc il
existe plus ce livre.
Et tu
on va en réécrire un.
Tu l'as pas mis à télécharger quelque
part gratos ?
Non.
Ah on sait pas faire ça. Nous on n'est
pas de cette génération. Donc
bon t'inquiète, on va te trouver un
jeune de notre communauté
qui va contacter et mais il y a aussi il
faut qu'on développe un peu plus parce
qu'on a pas assez développé je pense ce
qui ce qui nous [grognement] arrive
parce que quand on l'a écrit
Lia, on en parlait un petit peu mais le
22 novembre c'est le livre d'Éric Sapin
là qui parle de Lia qui disait Sad
on l'embrasse d'ailleurs. Il doit être
encore en Amérique du Sud. Ouais. Et et
qui disait que le 22 novembre
personne n'a n'a bougé
alors que c'était quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave puisque c'était
l'arrivée l'ouverture de vraiment de
chat de chat GPT et nous on en parle pas
assez parce que ça par contre je
dans le prochain livre on va en parler
ou
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
encore
On a touché le fond là parce queen fait
on a touché le fond parce que notre nous
nous n'avons plus de cerveau puisqu'elle
va penser avant avant nous hein. Il y a
il y a même des gens quelqu'un dans une
émission qui disait "C'est grave quand
même mais on pourra débrancher" et
quelqu'un je crois que c'était Ferry qui
disait "Ah ben non de toute façon parce
que elle pensera avant que vous allez la
débrancher." Donc en fait, elle elle
inhibra votre pensée. Donc c'est c'est
un outil qui est qui est d'une gravité
extrême et on plonge dedans, on va faire
de l'agriculture. Il y a déjà des gens
au niveau du vin qui font des
assemblages grâce à l'Ivin, à l'IA. Il y
a déjà euh des agriculteurs qui vont
utiliser l'IA pour savoir quel type de
de de semence ils vont mettre. Donc en
fait, on est complètement déconnecté. de
la pensée de la pensée là vraiment de la
pensée humaine de l'homme qui va qui va
décider de ce qu'il va faire puisque
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui le fera à sa
place et il s'en vente pas mais de se
dire que vous faites vos raisins et puis
c'est qui dit tu m'étends tu m'étends tu
m'étends donc on va on va encore plus
uniformiser cette société et je pense
que l'IA est vraiment la la chose la
plus terrible qui nous arrive
Et on a écrit un chapitre à partir d'une
exerge de Buffon. Buffon au 18e siècle
écrit "Il arrivera un moment où la
technique humaine sera tellement
puissante qu'il sera loisible à l'homme
de refroidir ou de réchauffer la
planète, mais il lui sera plus facile de
la réchauffer que de la refroidir." 18e.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle dans le problème de
l'atmosphère, on nous balance toute la
journée le problème du CO2. Le FIA ne
parle que du CO2. personne s'intéresse
au au problèmes de base. C'est pas du
tout le CO2 qui est responsable
majoritairement. Déjà rien que le
méthane, il est 60 fois plus actif en
réchauffement planétaire. Mais personne
ne parle des 100 millions d'hectares de
déserts que nous faisons chaque année.
Personne ne parle des 20 millions
d'hectares de forêt tropicales qu'on a
qu'on a bat. Personne ne parle des 20
millions d'hectares de béton que nous
ont sur terre. Personne ne parle des 80
milliards de machines qu'il y a sur
cette planète et qui chaque fois qu'elle
tourne chauffe qu'elle soit thermique ou
qu'elle soit électrique. Et ça personne
n'en parle. C'est extraordinaire
à délit quand il y a des périodes de
canicules, les gars ils allument tous
les mecs ont les moyens, ils allument
tous leur climes et on monte entre 50 et
60°gr, ça fait mourir les pauvres qui
sont dans la rue. Mais ça personne n'en
parle. Oui, c'est des pauvres des
pauvres formalis.
Non mais c'est intéressant de voir que
Oui oui, c'est intéressant de voir que
on se focalise sur le CO2 alors que les
plantes adorent ça et que il suffirait
de reboiser. Et par exemple, un autre
truc dont personne ne parle, nous on a
beaucoup travaillé dans les forêts
tropicales. Quand on est dans une forêt
tropicale, on est à 25 26°gr. Quand on
des fois pour faire un champ de soja, on
monte à 50 52 à midi. Or, la différence
thermique entre l'équateur et les pôles
forme ce qu'on appelle les alisés, les
vents très doux qui apportent de la
pluie et qui sont très très doux et qui
nous apportent la fraîcheur. Quand au
lieu d'avoir une différence entre 25°gr
et 0, on a une différence de 50° 0, on
transforme ça en ouragan.
Voilà. Plus
et les ouragans explosent au fur et à
mesure qu'on des forestes, les ouragans
augmentent de plus. Et ça, personne n'en
parle. Oh clud, c'est un petit orage, ça
fait tourner les éoliennes.
Oui. Non parce qu'avec un ouragan, elle
tourne pas, hein.
Et il les arrête tout.
Ça fait fonctionner les vendeurs
d'éolienne.
Voilà.
Et les réparateurs de toit de maison
et les producteurs de Balza. Voilà.
En au en Brésil.
Au Brésil à l'équiteur et
les vendeurs de Grèce.
Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes des petits
boutrains tous les deux.
Voilà. On a [rires] pas beaucoup de
choix, beaucoup de par contre si avec
notre vin on passe là c'est notre petit
paradis c'est notre vigne.
On ira boire ton pinard.
Ah ouais, il faudra que vous veniez le
boire parce que c'est super.
Je vais prendre quelques questions
internet qu'on va découvrir ensemble. Je
voudrais que on vous dit on vous a collé
l'étiquette que vous étiez d'extrême
droite des pitnies ainsi de suite.
Mais il faut faire un ha enfants. Tu vas
voir Fillard, tu dis voilà on nous a
catégorisé comme extrême droite, on peut
plus nous publier. Est-ce que tu peux
pas nous faire une petite place sur ton
étalage ? Je [grognement] suis sûr
que la nana chez Fire, elle va dire
comment elle s'appelle déjà ? Elise Boë.
Je suis sûr qu'elle va elle va te
trouver une petite place.
Autant utiliser la la propagande qu'on
t'a fait sur la tête pour te faire
publier. Non
non,
tu veux pas les faire publier GF ? Ah
toi tu es une puriste
à côté de Sarkozi.
Ouais ouais.
Non non ça va.
Non pas Sarkozi. Ah il a écrit son
bouquin en combien combien d'années ? Ah
non tu en 3 semaines.
Sem il resté 3 semaines.
Ouais il a ramassé le savon peut-être.
Ça ça a donné beaucoup de maturité d'un
coup.
[grognement] Je vous lis les questions
d'internet que je découvre
en ce moment. Tu voudrais te faire
publier par qui d'ailleurs ? Si par
exemple, je prenais mon téléphone que
j'appelais n'importe qui, tu voudrais
que j'appelle qui ?
Oh là
sois pas timide.
Tu es trop timide. Bon question
internet. Je prends la première. Claude,
est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaites aborder avant qu'on prenne les
les questions internet ? Un truc que tu
as pas
Non, je crois qu'on a
Tu as demandé à ta femme si elle voulait
aborder un sujet ?
Aborder un sujet du livre ou pas ?
Non, je crois qu'on a assez on a dit
assez de choses.
Question internet. Que pensez-vous des
enseignements au lycée agricole ? On a
déjà parlé mais je la lis quand même.
Nous avons la chance d'avoir ce type
d'établissement. J'y suis passé et j'ai
poussé leur profil chez vous. Que
pensent-ils des gens qu'ils rencontrent
et des retours qu'ils auraient s'ils en
s'ils en ont
s'ils y vont ? Bon ça on a déjà parlé.
Ouais, je crois qu'on a pas mal parlé
l'enseignement agricole.
Autre question internet que je découvre.
Bonsoir. Y a-t-il une solution face à
l'impasse dans laquelle nous sommes
alors que tout va bien ? Comment comment
pourront être gérés les citadins en cas
de rupture
de la normalité alors que la réalité ne
pourra pas se régler elle-même pour
interrogation.
Est-ce qu'on va voir des foules de
citadins débarqués à la campagne parce
qu'ils peuvent plus ils peuvent plus
becter parce qu'il y a plus de camion
parce que le gazoile coûte trop cher
donc les supermarchés sont plus livrés.
Moi je crois pas. Ils pourront pas se
nourrir.
Ils pourront pas de toute façon parce
que il y aura pas déjà à l'extérieur
parce que quand vous avez se nourrir
quand il y a un champ de blé, il faut il
faut faire de la farine. Est-ce qu'ils
seront capables de faire du pain ?
Est-ce qu'ils seront capables de planter
trois radis ? Moi je crois pas. On n'est
pas du tout à l'époque au moment de la
guerre où les gens partaient et euh
pouvaient trouver des des paysans qui
pouvait leur vendre avec du troc une
douzaine d'eux un lapin. Là c'est fini
ça. Il y a plus il y a plus ça.
Ils ont plus de poulailler les paysans.
Fin ils ont plus rien. Ils ont même pas
de jardin potager.
Et c'est réalisé. Ils ont pas de jardin
potager.
Je crois pas. Puis on est tellement on
est tellement je pense que la citadains,
ils sont aussi tellement dans les choses
qu'il les acquis. C'est-à-dire qu' pour
le le pour eux euh ce qu'on leur dit ou
revenir à à un certain bon sang, c'est
retourner à l'âge de pierre,
c'est-à-dire ne plus avoir la
possibilité de d'avoir son iPhone, la
possibilité de de pouvoir euh bah
s'offrir ce qu'ils ont envie qui sont
pas forcément [grognement]
l'indispensable. Et en fait, je crois
que c'est très compliqué parce que ils
ne veulent pas ils veulent toujours
avoir le même niveau de vie, le la même
possibilité de de s'acheter le le
dernier iPhone, le la game ou un truc
comme ça. Et euh pour aussi revenir à si
on voulait revenir à quelque chose de de
plus acceptable et de plus durable, il y
a un moment, il faudra aussi avoir une
forme de décroissance. on a pas parlé
mais on peut pas on peut pas consommer
de la manière dont on consomme pour même
en cas de crise et demain encore pire
demain et après-demain et il y a un
moment et on ils seront obligés de
d'être dans la décroissance. Ça va être
une obligation.
Ce sera une décroissance heureuse ou une
récession douloureuse ?
Récession douloureuse.
Ouais.
Parce que toi comme moi, Claude, tu as
remarqué qu'il travestissait la langue
française.
C'est absolument dramatique. Je vais te
lire un truc Claude. Tu vas me dire ce
que tu en penses. NGT ou NBT ? Le
Conseil de l'Union européenne valide
l'accord vers une conclusion en mai. Le
Conseil de l'Union européenne a annoncé
ce avril avoir adopté le texte de
compromis final sur les nouvelles
techniques génomiques NGT ou NBT. Si le
Parlement européen donne son feu vert,
alors de son vote en plaignière prévue
en mai, la le nouveau cadre
réglementaire devrait être s'appliqué à
partir de mi-202.
Ça te parle les nouveaux OGM là ou ?
Alors, le problème des OGM, de tout ce
qui est clonal, de tout ce qui est
manipulé génétiquement, c'est que ça n'a
aucune robustesse. Par exemple, si on
fait du semidirect sous couvert, c'est
pas la peine d'essayer de travailler
avec les clones, les variétés de clones
de blé ou d'orge, ça poussera pas
parce que ils sont tellement dégénérés
que ils ne peuvent pousser qu'avec des
produits chimiques. Donc, croire que
c'est avec de la génétique, de la
manipulation génétique qu'on va, c'est
du bidon absolu. C'est c'est je veux
dire c'est c'est le délire de de Mon
généticien qui le prix Nobel qui disait
"Mais les êtres vivants c'est que des
machines autorproductibles, c'est tout
quoi. C'est du grand n'importe quoi." Or
les anciens ils ont sélectionné des
variétés de blé, des variétés de pommes
adapté aux différentes régions de
France, beaucoup plus résilientes au
niveau changement climatique et cetera.
C'est alors que le clone lui, il faut
voir les maladies qui s'abattent sur les
clones dans la vigne, dans les dans les
un blé à l'heure actuelle. Moi quand
j'étais gamin, mon grand-père avait une
ferme. On traitait pas les blé.
Maintenant un blé s'est traité entre 4
et 6 fois. Un pomme une pomme de terre
s'est traité jusqu'à 20 fois. Un arbre
fruitier c'est jusqu'à 40. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont tellement dégénérés que s'il
y a pas tous ces pesticides pour les
protéger, on produit rien. Donc croire
qu'avec de la génétique, on va régler le
problème de l'alimentation, c'est du
c'est encore de l'illusion technologique
ça. Je suis maître du monde parce que je
manipule le l'ADN auquel je comprends
rien parce qu'ils comprennent rien à
l'ADN. Ils font croire qu'ils y
comprennent, ils comprennent rien.
Question internet. On entend sans cesse
que les agriculteurs n'arrivent plus à
vivre de leur métier. Dans ces
conditions, est-ce vraiment surprenant
que les jeunes ne veuillent plus s'y
engager ? Ça c'est sûr.
Oui, mais je ce que j'ai répondu tout
enfin je pense tout à l'heure si en fait
euh et effectivement les agriculteurs ne
vivent plus de leur métier parce que bon
il y a un problème de la manière dont on
achète le le produit et si on valorisait
le métier de d'agriculteur
dans à sa juste valeur euh à
l'équivalent d'un SMIG de quelqu'un qui
est à la chaîne et qui vise des boutons
des boulons ou d'un d'un jeune qui va
qui sera mon même salaire mais qui va
faire un produit de qualité, qui va
faire plaisir à quelqu'un quand on va
lui acheter ou ses pommes et tout, c'est
autre chose au niveau de de sa vie. Et
je pense que les il y a il y a aussi pas
d'agriculteur parce qu'en fait on a
dévalorisé ce métier et que les les gens
veulent pas y aller. Il y a pas que
l'argent. Il y a des gens il y a pas que
l'argent.
Question internet. [raclement de gorge]
Où en est où on en est dans la fertilité
des terres agricoles en France
aujourd'hui ? Deux points. Quelle source
et preuves chiffrées a-t-il à nous
recommander pour les mesurer pour
interrogation ?
Alors, il y a il y a une loi sur la
santé toute simple. Il faut pas que le
taux de matière organique soit inférieur
à 18 % du taux d'argile. Ça veut dire si
j'ai un sol à 20 % d'argile, faut pas
que je descende au dessous de 3,6 % de
matière organique. Or, à l'heure
actuelle, la moyenne des seuls agricoles
français est inférieure à 2 %.
La source de ça,
ça c'est c'est Changin, la faculté
Sangin en Suisse
et euh et ça c'est une donnée
fondamentale à la sortie de la guerre.
La moyenne de la tenue en matière
organique européenne c'était 4 %. Donc
ça marchait bien, c'était des sols qui
étaient peu sensibles à l'érosion. Euh
alors effectivement, il y avait pas les
engrais chimiques, donc on faisait pas
les rendements extraordinaires et
maintenant on est sur des sols qui sont
à moins de 2 %. C'est qu'on retire les
engrais, on ne produit plus que d'all.
Donc là là, on va être très mal.
C'est-à-dire que les anciens avec 4 % de
matière organique sans engrais chimique,
il faisaient 15 quâ taux 15 20 quintaux
en blé. Là maintenant, on en fait 70 60
70 avec les engrais. Mais là, on retire
les engrais. Et ben c'est pas 15 quinta
qu'on va faire, c'est 5. Et là ça va
être compliqué.
Bah tu sais ce qu'on va manger ? [rires]
Oui. [raclement de gorge]
Pétrole.
Ouais ouais. J'ai j'ai On aura un autre
régime gastronomique.
[soupir]
[grognement]
Question internet. Bonsoir amis
Bourguignon.
Pensez-vous que la sortie de l'Union
européenne serait une bonne option pour
faire du protectionnisme qui permettrait
aux agriculteurs d'avoir un meilleur
revenu et de pouvoir lever le pied sur
les rendements afin de soulager leur sol
?
Si c'est trop politique, vous êtes pas
obligé de répondre.
Je sais pas si sortir de l'Europe,
c'est forcément
faire des marchés comme on en fait avec
des pays comme le mercour ou les
alliances avec vraiment des pays. Mais
l'Europe, elle nous a apporté elle nous
a apporté certaines choses. Moi, je
serais pas je je pense pas que ça soit
c'est plus les dirigeants de cette de
cette Europe qui pose un problème, mais
l'Europe non. Parce que l'Europe c'est
un écosystème he on a le milieu
militernéen, le milieu tempéré, le
milieu froid. Donc ça permet de produire
tout.
Voilà,
il y a un mec qui fait une un
commentaire. Les Bourguignons vont
parler de labour sans doute de points
alors qu'un hectare sur de ne sont déjà
plus labourés. En France, la part des
terres cultivées sans labour technique
culturale simplifié ou de semidirecte
est devenue importante. Les ordres de
grandeur les plus cités sont environ 47
% des surfaces agricoles utiles n'est
pas labouré donne autour de 2007 issu
d'agressé. Comment interpréter ces
chiffres ? Bon c'est chat pété. [soupir]
[grognement] C'est un commentaire qui
vaut le coup qui vaut pas le coup.
Ouais c'est c'est en partie vraie.
Alors, il y a ce qu'on appelle la
technique culturale simplifiée. Il son
consiste à agiter, à remuer le sol avec
des machines. Effectivement, c'est plus
du labour
mais mais ça ça brutalise fortement les
sols et tout. Alors, il y a la le ce
qu'on appelle la technique culturale de
semirect souscouvert et ça des
agriculteurs qui savent maîtriser les
couverts pour semer. Pour le moment, il
y en a pas énormément. Ça se développe
hein. Nous on a fait le premier en 2000
premier agriculteur depuis ça se
développe et ça continue à se développer
mais ça se ralentit parce que l'État
n'aide pas cette technique. Normalement
en ça devrait être le programme numéro 1
de l'INERAD en recherche trouver les les
couverts pour chaque région de France.
Des couvertes c'est quand vous êtes en
zone méditerranéenne vous récoltez votre
orge fin juin. Il pleut plus beaucoup.
Donc faut trouver des graines des
espèces qui sont capables de pousser
sans sans flotte. Ça existe dans la
nature. Il y a tout ce qu'on veut, tout
ce qu'il faut. Il y a 400000 espèces de
plantes. Problème, c'est qu'il y a pas
de programme de recherche là-dessus.
Donc évidemment, l'agriculteur nous dit
"Ah ouais, mais ça pas couvert, il a pas
il a pas germé." En plus, il y a une loi
botanique qui nous dit que pour couvrir
complètement un sol et pas avoir de
mauvaises herbes, il faut au moins 12
espèces. Alors 12 espèces, c'est
compliqué à à à gérer, mais à six
espèces, on couvre déjà 90 % du sol.
Donc on limite considérablement les Mais
c'est une technique qui demande d'être
complètement changée. C'està-dire qu'on
met il faut mettre des engrais au
couvert sinon il poussent pas puisque la
la culture d'avant a tout vidé surface
du sol. Donc c'est toute une technique
qui demande à être complètement
améliorée et développée scientifiquement
et pour le moment ça avance très
lentement. Ça avance heureusement mais
très lentement et pas à la vitesse où on
je veux dire pour le moment je suis
désolé mais enfin la balance économique
de l'agriculture est négative hein donc
on va pas assez vite.
T'inquiète avec la guerre en Iran, ils
vont être obligés de se secouer un peu
les puces ou sinon ils vont se faire
couper la tête donc t'inquiète ils vont
bosser quand ils vont avoir bien peur
parce que quand la fin va commencer à
mordre
peuple la famille n'a pas d'oreill.
Ouais. [raclement de gorge]
Question fréquente mais bonne à rappeler
de points. Quels exemples d'agriculture
compétitif qui évitent les engrais de la
pétroagriculture pourinterrogation ?
Bah l'agricol,
il vient d'en donner une
le rotation rotation
association semi souscouvert
et puis vocation des sols, c'est-à-dire
ne pas ne pas violer un sol, être en
adéquation avec ce qu'il est capable de
produire et pas dire moi je veux
l'agrologie. Faire de l'agrologie et pas
de l'agronomie, c'est pas moi qui nomme.
Question internet que je découvre avec
vous. Est-il vrai qu'en France les
engrais étaient naturels notamment par
transformation des algues marines avant
l'utilisation massive des engrais
d'origine pétrochimique ? Pour
interrogation, il semblerait qu'une
directive de l'Union européenne
interdise aujourd'hui la culture d'algue
sur le territoire français. Alors il va
pas vérifier ça.
Alors toute la tout le maréchage breton
était basé sur le ramassage d'ivarec
avec des fameux chevaux bretons parce
que
il fallait qu'il soit costaud parce que
une charrette c'est des charrettes avec
un seul axe avait deux immenses roues
parce que quand ils étaient dans le
sable et qu'il fallait que le cheval
sorte la charrette, il fallait que les
hommes poussent derrière. Tu fais bien
le cheval, hein. [rires]
Et le [raclement de gorge] et et ce
Varek était riche en sel et donc ça
permettait de faire les fameux
chou-fleurs et chou breton puisque les
choux sont des espèces maritimes et qui
aiment le sel. Ça faisait les fameux
radis bretons. Donc ça faisait des
cultures très typées et très goûteuses.
Tout les asperges aussi tout ça ça a été
abandonné et on les var les utilise plus
alors que c'est du déchet de la mer et
les Bretons le réutilisé pour fertiliser
leur sol. Mais c'est fini parce que il
faut aller le ramasser. Enfin, c'est
compliqué quoi. Alors que l'engrais
chimique, c'est tellement simple.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder qu'on a pas abordé
? Lydia ? Non.
Lydia, tu as l'air blasé. Tu as l'air
blasé par nos politiciens. Tu as l'air
blasé de de la situation.
Oui, peut-être.
Ça te fait mal au cœur de voir la France
comme ça, de voir est-ce qu'on va
laisser ? Et je trouve que
je trouve ça a été très vite. Ça va très
très vite. Là si euh bon c'est vrai que
je suis peut-être une vieille dame mais
par rapport quel âge par rapport à
ça ne se dit pas.
Quel âge ta femme ?
Par rapport à
je peux te donner mon âge 74.
Oui mais quand tu l'as rencontré elle
était mineure. C'est ça ? [rires]
Voilà. C'est ça. Euh par rapport à ce
qu'on a vécu depuis qu'on travaille,
même quand on a commencé à travailler,
je pense bon, les sol était pas en
meilleur état, mais il y avait il y
avait encore je dirais des valeurs et là
il y a une accélération de la corruption
de et pour moi c'est une véritable
accélération. On est presque en perte de
démocratie. On a des on a des politiques
qui enfin dans dans le monde quand on
parle de Trump de de de Poutine de de
Netaniaou de de Macron aussi ou de Ching
Ping, on n pas parlé mais ce chinois
quiattend alors là lui il attend et puis
il bouffera qu'il aura envie je pense de
manger mais [grognement]
je trouve qu'il y a vraiment une
accélération et je oui j'ai un malaise
parce que je oui j'ai un malaise par
rapport à cette situation qui s'accélère
et qui n'a pas de on a l'impression
qu'on ne peut plus l'arrêter. C'est ça
qui est qui est aussi problématique. On
n' pas les clés, on n' pas le plan B
pour arrêter cette perte de de de notre
planète, de la biodiversité, de la
qualité, de la pensée. On peut on peut
plus, on ne l'arrête plus. Et h voilà,
ça me
Et c'est vrai qu'on parle moral, on est
on est à Cor, ils sont en train
d'arracher la moitié du vignoble à Cor.
Attends, quand je vais débarquer dans ta
région au mois de septembre pour faire
les vendanges, vous inquiétez pas tous
les deux, moi je vais vous mettre le
moral.
Et c'est vrai que c'est c'est dur à à
voir quoi parce que c'était quand même
un des fleurons de la France le vin. Ils
ont réussi à détruire même ça. C'est euh
Et donc nous on travaille beaucoup sur
le lieu, la notion de lieu, le lieu pour
faire des bonnes fraises, le lieu pour
faire du bon vin, le lieu pour faire la
bonne viande, ça c'est balayé
complètement.
On parlait de on a parlé beaucoup
d'agriculture mais moi ce qui me
surprend aussi c'est que en fait la
notion de goût c'est fini. Un étudiant
même ou même des gens qui ont les moyens
ils vont se faire ils vont satisfaire
d'aller manger des choses qui sont
insipites, qui sont
trafiquées, recomposé et tout. Alors que
avant c'était un vrai plaisir de manger.
C'est fini. Les gens, ils ont un
sandwich, ils poussent le cad ou ils
sont ils ont le sandwich, ils regardent
aussi leur portable. C'est fini. En
fait, cette communion autour aussi du
repas euh n'existe plus. C'était ça
faisait famille, ça faisait société, il
y avait une communion, il y a plus. Ça
c'est absolument terminé. Ou alors
même avant quand tu fais ton bœuf
bourguignon avec mamie dans la cuisine
qu'elle t'explique d'où est-ce que ça
vient, comment ça se fait, pourquoi il
faut laver les carottes, pourquoi il
faut faire dorer les lardons, trouver
les bons petits oignons qui vont bien.
C'est tout ça que tu trouves qu'on a
perdu ?
Oui, je pense qu'on a perdu aussi ça
c'est moi je je me souviens quand les
enfants rentraient et pourtant Dieu sait
si on travaillait. Bon bah la première
chose, il disait "Oh là ça sent bon." Il
soulevait le couvercle et pourtant je
faisais pas.
Voilà c'était et puis qu'est-ce qu'on va
manger et tout. C'est quand même quand
on regarde il y a des soirées des
parents qui disent "J'ai emmené en
soirée mes gamins manger parce qu'ils
veulent manger du mato." Bon je un jeune
homme mais en fait de la de la fast food
c'est quand même incroyable. Le goût
c'est aussi autre chose, c'est aussi un
autre regard par rapport à nos
territoires, par rapport au pays puisque
tu parles de la France. Et bien en fait
la notion du goût, la notion d'un lieu,
c'était aussi le patrimoine, c'était la
France, c'était et ça est en train de
complètement c'est de de disparaître au
nom de la facilité. On n' pas le temps
de cuisiner, on n pas le temps de ceci.
Euh mais oui, mais je fais mon sport,
c'est mieux que et même c'est aussi
c'est une relation en famille qui tombe
aussi parce qu'on prend pas le temps de
de à la limite de de préparer un bon
petit plat à son garage. Ça va pas la
tête, tu es en train de dire famille,
repas dans la même phrase, tu es coincé
là, tu es d'extrême droite.
Ouais,
pardon. Là là, je t'avais dit de pas
parler famille bouffe dans la même
phrase. C'est grave ça. Attention
Claude, tu veux demander ce que dit ta
femme ? Tu veux compléter ?
Non, je crois qu'elle a très bien
décrit.
C'est pas toi qui fait la bouffe à la
maison. C'est ça. Si.
Non, si on se partage bien. On se
partage bien tous les deux.
Elle est elle est meilleure cuisine.
Elle est meilleure cuisine. La chose que
je dirais, c'est que tout le monde est
très étonné. Mais il y a aussi une chose
qu'on Claude parlait des poètes et tout,
mais en fait si on ne fait pas son
métier avec amour, la renation en amour
ou amitié mais vraiment une relation
humaine, bah ça tient pas. Nous si on
tient 50 ans, mais
c'est parce qu'il y a le sexe. Ah
Claude, tu es d'accord avec moi [rires]
?
C'est important.
Ah bah oui,
c'est important. Mais s'il y avait pas
eu ça, et bien en fait on se serait
séparé parce que on n'est pas d'accord
sur tout quand on écrit un livre en
commun. Bah on n'est pas il y a des
moments mais il va dire ça moi je suis
pas d'accord ou je veux dire tu vas
faire ça et même dans les analyses quand
on regarde un sol un profil je ressens
pas forcément la même chose dans ce
profil les odeurs sont différentes. Je
je perçois plus les odeurs que Claude.
Il y a des choses que je vois plus alors
que lui il voyait pas. Et en fait ça
nous a fait de on a gravi des échelons
grâce à ça. On n'aurait pas eu ça
complémentarité.
Oui. Plus que de la complémentarité.
Donc c'est très important et il y a plus
ça là. On revenit on on peut plus parler
de bah oui d'amour. Voilà. à dire
d'amour, c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement Oui.
Et on a fait plus de 12000 analyses de
sol à travers le monde. Donc on avec
Lydia quand on descend dans un profil
creuser un trou, on commence à savoir
très rapidement. C'est un peu comme un
médecin qui a un médecin de famille qui
a travaillé pendant des années. La
personne rentre, il s'est déjà il y a
déjà une idée de la maladie qu'à la
personne. Ben nous, on arrive sur un
seul, on sait déjà qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui tourne par rond. et on a
fait faire une analyse statistique de ça
de ça et on a créé euh avec Liga une
théorie euh qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
haut lieu ? Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
endroit qui fera des bonnes fraises, de
la bonne huile d'olive, de du bon vin et
cetera. Et c'est important ça. C'est
important parce que
non, je ris parce que Claude c'est bah
vous l'avez vu Claude, il a pas sa base
de chiffre, il faut du chiffre mais il y
a [grognement] plein de choses. [rires]
C'est parce que c'est important
c'est parce que je lui dis tiens tiens
il faut faire comme mais il c'est truc
et ça me fait rire.
Là, je ris parce que bon
et tu te laisses faire toi ? Elle se
fout de [rires] ta gueule.
Ah parce que tu crois que bon.
Ah ouais, t'inquiète.
Euh
mais c'est vrai que c'est les chiffres.
Bon les amoureux là, on se détend un
peu. Vous êtes en train de me faire
rigoler. Euh Lydia, je voudrais que tu
me conseilles trois bouquins pour la
communauté.
Trois bouquins. Euh ben il y a celui
[grognement]
trois livres. Il y a celui que je viens
de j'ai oublié le
Éric Sadin.
Éc Sadin sur sur Lia.
J'ai bien aimé
bah là c'est un cadeau de ma fille.
Tr c'est un roman euh c'est sur le sur
le les relations humaines et puis le le
troisème
manifeste pour une agriculture grâ de
Claude et Lydia Bourignon. [rires] Pas
mal, pas mal. C'est interdit. Donc tu
vas m'en donner une un 4e.
J'ai pas le droit de faire de la
publicité pour moi. [rires]
Euh
dernier bouquin de Bruno Lemè sur qu'il
était très triste de pas avoir sauvé
l'industrie française. Tu veux pas le
dire ?
Non. Non,
ça va me faire gagner du temps. Tu
déconnes. [rires]
Non. Voilà.
Bon Claude, trois bouquins.
Je pense qu'il faut lire relire 1984.
C'est c'est quand même fondamental.
Enfin, c'est vraiment complètement
visionnaire de ce qui est en train de
nous arriver. Je crois qu'il faut lire
ça. Euh qu'est-ce que je dirais en ce
moment ? Moi, je suis en train de de
relire les frères Karamazov parce que
c'est tout tout le cœur de l'humanité et
tout tout le problème de la violence et
de je crois que c'est c'est très beau
aussi. Et puis quoi d'autre ? Comme
Maiavel, le prince un peu la politique
pour relire le prince de Maavel.
Claude, je voudrais que tu me donnes un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Une bouteille la mer, quelque chose qui
restera impérissable.
Apprenez à cultiver votre jardin.
Lydia, je voudrais que tu me donnes un
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Une
bouteille à la mer.
Aimez-vous.
Lydia et Claude Bourguignon. Merci.
Merci à vous, à toute l'équipe.
Merci
et on se revoit.
[musique]